welcome to the last word and we are here
without lord cognito actually that's why
i am doing the intro so he's actually
not feeling too well
we're gonna let him recover but we've
got travis as a co-host joining us today
how are you doing sir
mcclunkey and might i just say cog not
being here
wow that really didn't take long before
he abandoned his friends on the last
word and came down with the case of
too big for you itis uh ibantis we we
all know that's terrible
yeah i know it's it's he really he can't
he's been leaking all over the place
oliver's room um he's uh he just don't
come back from that
he has amnesia too he can't remember
anybody with fewer than 20 000 twitter
followers
oh man that's the worst kid i've heard
of that it's a bad deal yeah
yeah it's a really really bad case of uh
of too big for you itis he's he's just a
big shot now so
anyway uh let's continue introducing our
guests ah
no but yeah before we go any farther we
got another awesome guest so let's get
this episode started welcome to the last
word episode 157
as we take our seats around the campfire
on this warm summer evening the world of
destiny is heating up the sandbox has
shifted the eaz is in the air
and the vault of glass is showing us
what time lost really means to discuss
all of this and more tonight we are
joined by a very special guest
while she didn't get to spend a lot of
time gaming growing up she recently has
chosen some great franchises to get lost
in between the worlds of zelda and
diablo
action adventure seems to speak to her
but destiny 2 has merged many genres and
she's been hooked
on clicking heads ever since so let's
welcome to the campfire a true canadian
who enjoys sipping on her tim horton's
coffee while reading her latest book
staying cool in the summer with some
advanced gg popsicles
putting on a clinic at the gym with her
excellent form
losing yet winning in her own beer
olympics and shutting down players and
crucibles since season the drifter
the one the only very swol hat i mean
small hat
sarah how are you doing tonight
i'm doing really great i'm very happy to
be here
introducing you gotta do the introducing
you he and i do it different i can't
copy him i gotta do my own thing
yeah you gotta have your own style yeah
yeah yeah
so how are you doing though welcome yeah
are you good
i'm good i'm good didn't play much
testing last week to be honest
especially with everything going on i'm
kind of like
feeling like oh no like i've got so much
to catch up on but i'm excited to
talk a little bit more about like the
patch and solstice and
master uh vog and yeah and
you know hear what everybody else is
thinking too cause
yeah we've got a lot to talk about
investing but we want to get to know you
a little bit first a little more so
anybody who
of your communities in chat or finds
this later on we have a very nice lady
here
so first i want to actually talk about
kind of your gaming history and where
you get started which
has actually been fairly recent so i
mean growing up seemed like you didn't
have a lot of access and then you kind
of fell into this stuff more recently so
how has your journey through gaming been
for your life so far like what have you
where did you get to play any when you
were younger at all
got a little tease and then you got into
it so what what's your gaming journey
been like
yeah so growing up like we just didn't
have any consoles like it wasn't i
wasn't i didn't have a huge interest in
gaming we moved around a lot
so um i didn't really know a ton of
people that were into
any forms of gaming my dad did however
have a nest
and one singular uh mario game so we
played
quite a bit of that uh and i played it
with my grandma actually she was really
good at it
um so played a certain amount of that my
brother who's quite a bit younger than
me he got a
nintendo ds and so i would occasionally
play on that some pokemon games
and we had a playstation which i was
allowed very very little time on but it
was usually just like some basic racing
games i was never very good
um and i would often like lose interest
pretty quickly
not knowing how to like progress in
levels or
um stuff like that so i just kind of
like dabbled
and then in my last relationship
actually it was my ex that got me into
gaming so um we started playing on his
xbox and i started playing breath of the
wild on the wii u
um and then we built my pc
in 2019 after i started playing around
on his and i did
uh i like made a steam account and
started playing destiny 2 on his
computer because he was like i think
you're really going to like it based on
the games that we've been playing
and he was really passionate about it so
it became something that we played
together
and then we built my first pc which i'm
still running most of the same things
that i built it with in 2019
that's not that old that's not that bad
you're like 2019 my two-year-old pc
god so old i need to be fair with how
quickly everything progresses
i just can't keep up yeah i also didn't
stream at the time
so pretty impressive it was streaming in
mind
that's the important thing yeah yeah i
did i didn't i had no
ambitions of streaming i'd never i
didn't know what twitch was when i
started gaming so
um so yeah and then your ex introduced
you into destiny huh
yes yes yes we were taylor for six years
he introduced me to a lot of my hobbies
no regrets
um and yeah it was a big thing that we
did together as well
and then um i started to kind of feel
like i wanted to
meet more people in the community that i
resonated with personally rather than
just through his gaming friends and
i wanted to kind of meet you know my own
group of people to hang out with and so
that's why i started streaming
but i when i started streaming like i
did not spend time on twitch like i
had no idea what i was getting myself
into it was super spontaneous i
literally was like i'm gonna start
streaming and i went to the store bought
their last
their last webcam i remember i had to
ask for it because it was behind the
counter
oh man and i started streaming the next
day and like it was just super
spontaneous i told my family and friends
about it and they started supporting me
and this was
uh june of last year so
yeah you've been strapped to a rocket
for a year then that's impressive
yeah it's pretty wild that's crazy
yeah i would say that's pretty that
pretty much sums up the journey but
uh pretty much once i started gaming
more regularly
uh i've been hooked ever since i can't
not
have something on the go and i play
around with a lot of different games off
stream as well even though i primarily
play destiny 2 on stream um yeah
i saw one of your favorite games was
elder scrolls online have you played a
new blackwood expansion
so i actually can't have both destiny 2
and
eso on my computer at the same time okay
2019 pc 2019 piece holding you back over
here
they like have to be on my c drive and i
just don't have a space
to have both because it just doesn't run
well uh otherwise
and the graphics in that game are really
good so
you know you don't want to be playing on
like you know terrible graphics so
i have put esl on hold i have not
touched it in about a
year um so i haven't most recent
expansion that i think i
dabbled in was where they introduced
dragons
whichever one that was i don't remember
the name of it
but i dabbled in that one yeah somerset
i think yep
that sounds right yeah it's good yeah
yeah i also
have a lot of friends that played it and
i think it is one of those games it's
good to have friends to do dungeons with
and
yeah so yeah it's one of those games
that i always boot up
regularly and i try to uh get into it
and then i just always fall off the
wagon because
i get such a big game it's huge it
should take your whole life
if you're not careful oh my gosh i get
so sidetracked with quests like
and then i'm like i'm i haven't
accomplished anything in
six hours of gaming but it's fine like i
mean that's what i
love games like that but i do get a bit
overwhelmed sometimes and i'm like i
don't know where to
one of the reasons why i'm always afraid
to touch the witcher well i've heard
witcher 3 is an amazing game like the
show is really good
and i wish i forgot to mention the
witcher hasn't there is an end
there is an end yes but it is large from
what i've heard
so i'm the type of person like i do get
very like into games
and i get super sidetracked and i like
to finish them
and i did the witcher in about 120 hours
the witcher 3.
so that's where like i would basically
like i pretty well stuck to the main
story but i would like between
each like main story quest i would go do
a few side quests
to switch things up a little bit because
once i'm done the main quest i have a
hard time going back and just doing
because i'm like well there's no purpose
now like i like to have a set
goal so like for me it's like okay
introduce me like a new main quest
and yeah i'm back in the game i'll do
more story like more side quests i'll go
exploring more but
um other than that like for me it's like
i like to have that in goal so i will
i like split up the main quest with a
bunch of side quests and it took me
about a
about 120 hours and i played the entire
thing last year
in like march when quarantine started
literally
i dated the witcher 3 for about two
weeks like i did not do anything else
i you would not i didn't go to the gym i
didn't eat i like
literally this is how she lost her ex we
get it now
yeah he supported me it's fine
he's a little jealous of girl but you
know i mean
have you seen henry cavill i think
everybody else you've seen him yeah
he's a bit the show is so good too i
highly recommend them with your three
though so good
and two so good play two you can skip
one i didn't play two you bet
i give you permission to skip one two is
kind of hard to get into just because
it's a little outdated but the story is
so good and then three is obviously just
like one of the best
ever it's one night i i think i did
literally every side quest in that game
it took me like
six months of playing every day yeah i
think it was like 300 hours or something
like that maybe a little more yeah
yeah that's what's daunting because like
trying to do content at all
destiny for five thousand problems
that's the problem
destiny occupies so much of your time
like i have to force myself to go do
variety which has been healthy to take
breaks from destiny believe me after
covering it for so long
but it's like i'm working through mass
effect and even i finished mass effect 1
so i'm a third of the way
the worst one from what i understand the
world building is really cool and that's
the thing is like i'm kind of like you
guys it's like i started and it's like
yeah here's the quest but there's some
side quests you could do
the side quests and mass effect one
those are fairly repetitive but it was
like
but every time you'd like it was the
actions of what you would do or like
repetitive and i'm like
okay but then you'd get into a
conversation and those were the best
parts of mass effect 1. i'm like all
right this is legit like cool the world
that it was building and then the fact
that i know there's two more to go with
it is gonna be really cool but
man that was even a decent chunk hours
and every so often it's just
it the idea of like witcher that's a
hundred plus
it's it's just a lot so it's somewhere
at some point i joked with uh black
wings i was like if i ever do like a
charity stream
and there's like a decent milestone if
we hit that i might throw it out there
as like a reach goal and he's like dude
you just give me the day and the number
we'll get there so seriously it's so fun
you'd love it
no yeah well sometimes i forget you only
play destiny i play that's one way to
live i don't only play i used to only
play because i missed like
breath of the wild mostly i played like
seven hours of that and i need to go
back and play that i've missed a lot
200 some hours in that game
when destiny is now like a tuesday game
or now it's like i'll play you in a
month game which we'll get to in a
little bit
like now is the time when i can go enjoy
other stuff so i'm honestly happy we're
kind of at that state now
um yeah but yeah speaking of kind of
your history with destiny as well
you how did you two things one you
started with your ex you guys must have
like ended on amicable terms because if
your ex like is like
this is his focus we're gonna play the
game together and then you're not with
them anymore
to still play the game like there's got
to be a transition there like how did
that work out
well i mean it was like
so like we were together for a long time
and we didn't necessarily end on
a couple terms everything's fine now but
it was it was
a destiny became more than just about
our relationship at that point like i
did meet more people through streaming
started playing with other people
i'd play on my own a lot like he would
play on his own a lot
um we were in the same clan at the time
i ended up leaving clan and just like
meeting new people and it was fine it
was like
weirdly enough i've only ever matched
him once even though we live in the same
city
in crucible i hope it's crazy please
tell me you beat him
oh come on oh no
it was too fresh it was too fresh at the
time oh
if that ever happens again we need the
tweet and be like crush them
we need the kill clips
we need that so much yeah yeah oh no my
control key broke i don't know what
happened
and i was like but yeah no it was it
just became it became more than that
and like i by the time we split like i
had
i've been playing the game for a couple
years so um
so yeah it was it became more than that
and obviously by this point too
uh because we split last october i had
like a platform on twitch too so like i
was
i'd met a lot i met a lot of new people
by last october
so i mean that was before that was
before i like really took off
but like yeah exactly yeah destiny is
forever
that's part of it i was like i kind of
figured i mean you had grown you
exploded on twitch like you had a reason
to stay
but the other guy you started in the
season of the drifter
how does somebody start in drifter and
be like
this is where i want to spend a lot of
my time this is the game
but like put yourself in my shoes for a
second like i have no
experience with fps games like i this
was such a new realm to me this was like
my first like
major pc game on pc i think before
destiny 2 i was playing elder scrolls
online
actually no i think i started playing
elder scrolls after i was playing
destiny um but i was playing elder
scrolls online around the same time
and then before that i played a little
bit of path of exile which is like a
really different game to get into
diablo so yeah very much diablo style
and uh so then destiny 2 was like the
first game that had like all this
movement and
um i hadn't tried warframe yet at the
time so like
very different type of game and i was
terrible
like i guys i didn't even know how to
you work a mouse and keyboard
like i had no clue what i was she's come
a long way ladies and gentlemen
so this was early 2019 so that that was
me so i was like
just exploring the storyline and
uh just doing pve stuff like i was a
strikes gamer right like i
at the very beginning like that was what
i was doing i i played gambit for a
while which was a big step for me
playing with other people
like matchmaking and like it being more
competitive that was a big step for me
so and then me going into crucible that
was just like
i remember i was so nervous and like i
had no clue what i was doing i was i was
really bad i was double primary
for a long time and then i don't know
something clicked i started watching
other people play
and uh yeah i
now i'm i'm i've been a pvp main for
over a year like it's been a year and a
half
two years almost like i only stayed in
the pve realm for about six months
before i was bored
what clicked what made that switch
because obviously you're starting in
strikes you've done
zeldas and elder scrolls a lot more pde
generally focused things
when did you switch over is it just like
your progression of like i'm picking up
this quick and people are dying on
account of my clicks or like
what started you down the path of pvp so
hard because
obviously if you're a man now that's a
thing i think for me it was actually
it's my competitive side like i grew up
playing sports i played lacrosse for
eight years like i am super competitive
and i love winning
i love winning but i also love
challenging myself and getting better at
something and i think with pvp
because i was starting from nothing i
saw myself get better
in very obvious ways and it's like
you're it's represented by numbers right
like you can watch your
your kd go up you can watch your number
of kills go up you
like you know you try out weapons that
you're
and then you're like oh [ __ ] like i'm
really good with this type of weapon and
like
it was just i think for me it was it was
i loved to see that progress
and feel like i was getting better
like so it was personal it was i was
being competitive with myself but also
winning or like also
it was it was just really bringing out
my competitive side and you don't get
that in pve you don't get that at all
so or at least i didn't um
so yeah that i think was the biggest
thing for me
nice so i went from training rules to
try hard in like
six months i i mean
yeah i guess so um i wasn't that good
right away
i started i didn't probably didn't play
my first pvp match until
six months into playing destiny 2. and
then
and then i basically just stuck with it
from there i remember i would just like
get up in the morning and drink my
coffee
because i was uh either in school or i
was serving at the time
so i worked in the evenings and i'd get
up and drink coffee and i would turn on
some music and i would just
vibe out in some 6v6 it was great just
by myself because at the time i didn't
have my very many gaming friends
so it was just yeah
so quite a little journey been a journey
it's a great story yeah but like my
experience is a lot
is a lot different from other people
because i just don't
i i never played fps games like prior to
this
like at all so there are a lot of people
who are not thrilled
i've been doing this for years and she
can kick my butt yes she can
but that's one of those things like you
really did pick it up fast because i
know some people it's like picking a
mess and keyboard
is very very foreign to play much less
like
because you know some people grew up
with you know even two thumb sticks on
controller depending on how you play
is difficult if you haven't picked up
like one going one way
and it's just a whole lot so the fact
that you picked it up is for one
impressive and two just kind of goes to
show for your resilience but that also
kind of goes into
a little offbeating topic i wanted to
kind of touch on as well
is fitness for you seems definitely to
be like a big thing i see through your
twitter thread and i think that's really
cool but i was kind of i
got a tease of it as you've done sports
for so long but
sports lacrosse have you always been
into that more did you get into like
feels like you're almost into more like
lifting weights and like heavier
intensity now like
how's your progression been through just
you know staying fit and healthy for you
uh yeah so my fitness journey started
when i was quite young like i've always
played sports
um i've dabbled in pretty much every
sport you can think of but i started
playing lacrosse competitively which
in canada it's box across not just field
lacrosse so we have both
so box lacrosse is like you play in like
a hockey arena but you're running
so it's in hockey off season so a lot of
people who play hockey
a lot of people who play hockey do
lacrosse and off season because it's
great conditioning and it keeps them in
shape
yeah but it's like you have gear on like
it's like very very rough
uh it's a rough sport compared to field
lacrosse which is the one that i think
most people in the states would know
about
um which that one's more of like a
summer sport whereas lacrosse is like a
spring early summer sport it's only a
few months long
and uh competitive side development yeah
yeah
so played that for a long time um so i
was really into running when i was
younger i've run like a couple
10ks half marathons and then i started
lifting
once again my ex introduced me to
lifting early on in our relationship
which was about uh so this was six years
ago i've been lifting for about six
years now
and um i've always been like i started
well i started lifting in high school
casually because that was part of our
training and conditioning for
lacrosse but then i really got into it
in my early 20s
and i've dabbled in power lifting some
olympic lifting
um and at one point i was like full on
doing like bulks cuts
i was counting macros like i've
literally been to every extreme and i
was gyming six days a week my gym
sessions were like two plus hours long
like
yeah it was for me it was like a it was
my life like it was a lifestyle
oh and you go that hard yeah me too me
too big yeah
now i'm at the point where i just i just
do it because i enjoy it i like feeling
strong i do it to maintain my muscle
um and because i know that it's gonna
help me with my longevity
uh in my life uh it's good for your
bones like it's
i just feel better i feel like my joints
work better like
i feel more more competent capable i'm a
five foot two female i like to feel like
i'm strong right
so i yeah so um
so yeah now i just like i go like two to
three times a week right now like
nothing too crazy
um and i've never done any like official
like nutrition or
exercise uh like training but
i um have learned a lot over my six
years of lifting like there's so much
information out there so
i've learned a lot so i like to share a
certain amount of it but um
but yeah i my cardio sucks now i used to
be a runner i'm not anymore
and uh i pretty much just lift heavy
weights and put the bag out again
that is totally fair no like i literally
my wife and i have been lifting
kind of a way to stay relatively
reasonable in the mint like the last
year being stuck at home
and we have at least enough weights at
home to do it and then every soft just
this last couple days we did legs
and like you know we'll you'll do heavy
stuff here and there we have a friend
who actually got a squat rack set up in
one of his rooms we actually have a way
to do that which is
not an easy thing for home stuff but he
actually would kind of do that on the
weekends
but like the one that ruins me it's
always
uh like a lot like high volume lunges
for whatever reason totally like i'm
sitting in this chair right now when i
go to get up i'm just gonna moan like an
old man and then when i go to sit down
my butt is still sore two days later
so it's just one of those things but it
is one of those weird ones
it doesn't have to be the heaviest thing
like you know we'll dead and we'll squat
you know do the big stuff and then it's
just like
two 15 pounders and just but it was like
75 on each leg and by the time you're
done it's just like
i'm gonna cr and it's just so much worse
but it's one of those things you figure
out yeah
i can lift some heavy stuff and then you
do the the light stuff just ruins you
and you're like yep that's just humbling
i'm back to normal
i did lunges literally today so i i feel
you sorry for tomorrow because that's
gonna be fun
yeah yeah travis what's your uh fitness
routine
uh he's like i play games and try and
stay awake
no i jog i run i run like 15 20 miles a
day that's been my
i can't do lifting like you guys i don't
have the body there's a difference
yeah there's a different amount of like
endorphins you get from
running though i do miss it i like i'd
like to get back into it a certain
amount because
yeah the endorphins you get from cardio
yeah
lifting doesn't quite give me the same
rush
they talk about like the runner's high
too and people are like i signed up for
a video game podcast what the hell are
you guys talking about right now
yeah but no it's like the runner's high
lifestyle podcast
yeah but like that runner's high is one
of those things people like joke about
and i've hit the runner's wall
that sucks too but like the runner's
high is some of those things i do
fitness kickboxing too
so that one's always a lot of fun but
every so often it's like
you either have good days but sometimes
whether you're in at the moment or
you're going or if you're running you
just kind of hit that perfect song and
you're just like
you go it is i love that yeah yeah i
haven't run in a while either because i
did
uh it was a spartan beast so it ended up
being about 15 miles and about
two-thirds of the way through my t-band
just like
lit up and i was like walking for the
rest of it and i haven't been running
much since that's why i try and do
less distance and the kickboxing still
definitely will destroy me for cardio so
it works
yeah just let that heal up yeah well
one more piece before we get into the
current activities
back to the thing of destiny because
that tangent had to happen um
classes for destiny seems like you've
kind of touched on them all
but she's a titan now she is in the she
is one with the titans right now so
kind of wanted to see if you have like a
favorite that you've experienced
or just like why you're on the tight now
if you're just kind of in a cycle
what's the what's the love of the
classes how you feeling about them
yeah it's really just like depends on
the meta i think that the meta makes a
big difference for me and like
how i make my builds uh depending the
meta is huge so for me slug shotties
just feel really good
on my titan build like i get going with
my shop
my my chaperone and i've got my dude
marchers on
with bottom tree hammers and it just
feels good feels good i
yeah it's just fun it's a really fun
build
um that being said i was a hunter made
for a long time
that's what i started on and i didn't
switch
to another any other classes until last
year actually
i finally made a warlock male warlock
which was
my first mistake but it's fine it's fine
where's cognito when you say these
things oh our guest needs to be here our
yeah my co-host needs to he's he's a
die-hard warlock so you're like i made a
male warlock and it was wrong
i'm gonna have to clip this one later
for him he's just gotta see when you're
talking about warlocks i think you have
to call it die
easy yeah okay okay yeah
there you go funny very funny so i i
remained warlock for quite a while and
it was actually i was meeting warlock
when i started streaming last june
and i was i was like uh i was an
affidian's
warlock on nova bomb actually
and uh that's when i started learning
how to snipe
so i found it easier to learn how to
snipe on a warlock than a hunter
and so i basically mastered sniping last
year
um i was a sniper main for quite a while
uh
and this was when like revoker was still
a thing so i got revoker like
you know it's a good way to learn yeah
and uh and then i kind of started
switching back and forth went back to
hunter for a while then finally made a
titan
didn't spend any time on titan until i
think like early this year when i
i started scrimming in uh like last
september
so i started with scrim queens and then
i joined the band cam girls which is uh
was at the time of scrimmage clan we
don't scrim much these days just because
of the current
metas and we just haven't a lot of
people aren't playing the game at the
moment
which is fine but um but i was screaming
a lot and i realized that i wanted to be
able to
um because of scrim rules you need to be
able to adapt
to like a lot of different play styles
so if somebody else
only plays you know dawn blade warlock
with beloved and dire promise you need
to be able to adapt to be like okay no
problem
like i can use thorn and shotgun on
a titan like no problem so for me it was
about
wanting to just be comfortable on
all classes so that's what i did and i
started just playing all three on a
weekly basis and i just would rotate
through all three of them
all the time and i just like every day
i'd get on and be like oh what do i feel
like playing today
we would switch it up and sometimes i
would get chat to vote for me just to
make a decision
and um yeah so that's that's kind of how
i do it now i just play on all three
every single week depending on the map
for trials
too like i liter every weekend like i
usually try to get
flawless on all three characters but
otherwise it's like just whichever
character is playing the best
oh i get carried it's okay
you're part of a team there don't get
yourself
but yeah it depends on the map like i
i just kind of switch it up depending
currently i think i'm having the most
fun on titan it was funny
someone came to my chat last week and
was like why do all
girls play on titan i was like
that's a ridiculous statement but yes
continue yeah i was like
first of all i'm not sure that me being
a girl has to do with me playing on
titan
but also we don't like i and it was
funny because it was like literally
right after i'd literally just
switched to my titan from hunter and i
was like but when i'm playing on hunter
people are like why do all girls play
hunter and i'm like
man you just can't win like it was just
such a silly but now every time i'm like
yeah titan's my favorite right now i'm
like
all self-conscious about it like is that
stereotypical of me
i don't know in my experience no i was
like most of the stuff i listen to a lot
of pvp people especially in general guy
or girl tend to lean hunter period
that's just what i'm here for yeah you
look at the stats like yeah
especially casual players i find most
are on hunter
but yeah anyway
zoe is like why do all girls play insert
anything they're just gonna try and
stare
there's a girl playing a video game a
stereotype
yeah it just yeah i don't i didn't want
to honestly harp on that stuff what i
was going to say is like just wanted to
give you props if nothing else because
being a female in the gaming and
streaming and all of that community
you got to have some thick skin in the
first place but just
it seems like you got a community like
coming through chat and everything but
it's like it's not an easy thing to do
people can get a hard time there's jokes
about you know some of the stuff you see
on twitch and stuff getting banned and
you can think about that all you want
but just somebody who wants to actually
be like hey i want to play games on
twitch
there's so much stuff that the other
side is not even gonna think about that
you have to deal with and it's just
yeah not asking too many questions just
gonna say props to you for actually
doing everything that you do because
at the end of the day uh like as uh in
any kind of um you know more like
like like as a woman like from my
experience like
you can't win you're like you're
you're people come after you whether you
do or you don't like no matter what you
do there's something that people want to
say something and that's
being a content creator in general is
like that you can't
be perfect you can't when there's always
going to be people that have something
to say
and are trying to bring you down just
because they want to make you
feel like [ __ ] like that's just the way
it is um
and i will be honest i definitely don't
have the thickest of skin
uh all the time because i'm human and
i'm also a very empathetic human which
means that
words hurt like it's just the way that
it is um
but i also don't think that you know
like that like that's okay like i can
still be a content creator without
perfectly thick skin it's it's you know
i can stand up for myself
and i can um it's okay for me to feel
hurt by certain things
even though it's expected and yeah we
just kind of
my community is really great and they
always have my back and you know it just
helps really weed out the
the shitty ones you know you're like
okay you know what you're not cool let's
let's get you out of there
that's the biggest thing is like you
just gotta be quick on the uh click on
the delete button for some people just
be like
you're not worth my time just see you if
you're making me uncomfortable i'm gonna
ban you like i am under no obligation to
keep you here and that's one thing i
love about streaming is i have full
control over
who stays and who doesn't so you're
right about
you know not being able to win but you
can win at crucible
can win a christmas is the ultimate
revenge i think isn't it
uh speaking of which i had a question
for you and let's make this a segment
we'll call the segment
let's help ibontis that's the name of
the segment all right and the
surroundings this segment
is uh give me your top tip for not
sucking at crucible
what is one thing that sort of like
helped you
kind of turn that corner to to not being
like
you know the ebontuses of the world
basically
[Laughter]
there's so many good tips all right i
got i got my notepad over here
let me get my legal pad i'm ready okay
uh
uh i'm trying to think of like the ones
that like really clicked with me
early on um tip number one
i'm ready probably
oh my god okay can i give two top tips
go three yeah
go three i got space
one of mine is positioning was a big one
and
like major cues was like staying along
walls trying not to just be in an open
space
all the time just you know hugging walls
um
you know you know peeking corners slowly
um peaking with your teammates like
those are really important positioning
cues
um also if you're sniping um peeker's
advantage
so another like positioning queue um
and then the other one is probably
oh i've totally forgotten it now that i
said that one um
oh knowing when to and when to engage
when to continue engaging and when to
pull back
when to disengage that was a big one so
um
you know if knowing that if you've
missed a shot
and you're up against someone who's
really good at three taps like you get
out of there
and heal you get out of there and heal
and get back to your teammates or
if you're um you know you're better than
them
like being able to stay in the
engagement longer even though you're
down to like one tiny tiny health
because you know you can win
so there's that was a big thing knowing
because for a long time
i would disengage too quickly and i
remember people being like like sarah
you could have won that like why'd you
disengage like why did you run away and
i was like i don't know they hit me and
i was low and they were like yeah but if
you'd stuck through it
just on your you know strafing like you
would have had it in the bag
like and then there's certain times
where a trade is really good too like in
trials sometimes just getting a trade is
better than nothing
so knowing when to engage and disengage
and positioning are probably like my two
top tips
nice yeah those were like ones that like
really clicked with me yeah positioning
makes sense a lot but like when to
when to know when you may have lost the
battle so you can go in the war seems to
be like a bigger thing
i sometimes catch myself doing sometimes
just throwing my body out there like i'm
just trying to knock out bounties i
don't even care but if i'm actually
conscious about it and start playing for
a little while
that is one of those things that i
noticed it's like as you said sometimes
you think like oh i'm being too cautious
i could have been in there a little more
or on the other side it's like that was
stupid i should have
pulled back because i had the
opportunity to yep
yep yeah i think positioning is when the
game is working correctly
aka like not when stasis was the thing
position
is like the key to also mess up
positioning as well
yeah yeah exactly but the the um
like the whole positioning game when gun
play is what wins rather than
you know a single powers that frees you
and then kill you uh
i'm still trying to get out of that
mindset um
but uh i think positioning is very
important and so i think my top tip like
the thing that made me in destiny anyway
go from like
being you know decently good to okay uh
to being like very good especially back
in the d1 days was
uh my group of friends has something
called the two second rule which is i
was gonna that was my that's gonna be my
third one the two second roll
huge that's that's i can't thank for
sniping too like if you're trying to
learn how to snipe
especially i can't remember who coined
that was it asked across or someone i
can't i want to say it was asked to
cross yeah
somebody coined this term but they sent
a nomad i feel like did a video on that
too
i've heard yeah maybe maybe going around
definitely gotten a lot more traction
one person like definitely did it first
but i don't i i think it was astrocross
but
i can't remember who it is but anyway
the two second rule if you don't know
what it is is that
if you're standing somewhere in crucible
and you have been staying there for more
than two seconds
it actually no longer makes sense for
you to stand there because all you're
doing is giving the other team more
information and you're giving
them the ability to kind of control the
battle because they know where you're at
you're a known quantity and all you're
doing is kind of just like taking up
space but
if you're constantly changing your
positioning you keep playing with your
radar
yeah playing through radar and you get
to you get to control the combat on your
own terms and that's like
i think the most important thing to
winning crucible crucibles to just like
don't just stand there and like expect
to win just by
you know team shooting and like hard
scoping and doing like a static kind of
push you need to be like dynamic and
willing to roll the punches and do stuff
that
they're not expecting and uh once i
started playing that way
it was just so much uh easier to win to
win uh crucible matches so that's my
talk yeah
yeah 100 agree and i mean it also
that rule if you can follow that rule it
also avoids the game feeling slow
because if you just stand in one spot
like
sure maybe on certain maps and in
certain metas standing in one spot the
whole game
and team shooting is going to get you
where you need to be like with dmt and
gl's and stasis
but it makes the game so slow and boring
so
if you don't want to play slow and
boring follow the two second rule it'll
make you better at the game in the long
run so that no matter what meta you come
across
you can win and it keeps it interesting
so yeah on the other side on more
specifics
do you guys have any tips when it comes
to somebody who wants to
get better at sniping and somebody wants
to get better at shotguning
because those are kind of two extremes
of the special weapons i'll take
shotgunning on this one you cannot
sure yeah i recently went back to
shotgunning mostly
i'm trying to get back into sniping
again um since the flinch changes i
definitely
stopped sniping a little bit like i i
didn't notice a huge change in my skill
level but
um but i decided i was just more
consistent with my shotgun
but when i first started learning how to
snipe two second rule was one thing
um that was a big one because
positioning when you're sniping is so
different than as a shotgunner
your positioning is is super different
so
it's learning the lanes on each map
which sometimes can take a couple games
so if you're going into trials learning
the lanes that people are peaking
a lot of times they'll pick the same
lanes over and over again
keep to that two second rule though
change up your lane that you're peaking
um don't get stuck in your scope too
long um
and don't run around with your sniper
out do not run around with your sniper
keep your primary out your primary
should still be your number one weapon
that you're trying to use
um use your sniper as a as a
as a it's supplementary to your primary
um because team shooting is still
definitely a big thing
if you're going for that first pick
though make sure you get to that lane
fast before the other team
um and yeah just try and figure out
where they're peaking
as far as the aiming goes it just comes
with time i just and my rule is that if
you really want to learn how to snipe
get into a sick just keep going 656
games don't put your sniper down
even though i just said put your sniper
down in like more competitive game modes
if you're learning how to aim with your
sniper just don't put it down keep
keep your sniper out and just keep
trying to click heads because it'll
you'll figure out where that hitbox is
and every sniper's difference maybe for
the first little while to stick to one
with the same zoom zoom same scope and
um get comfortable with it before you
start switching it up
so good tips
yeah uh my tips for shotgun are
uh become one with the ape try to make
like animalistic
monkey sounds while you're running
around with your shotgun
uh no no my actual tip is kind of
similar to yours actually for shotguns
which is
i feel like when people say like oh i'm
running shotgun you know they take their
shotgun out as soon as the match starts
and they start running
and that might win that might win the
day for like the first
round you do it if you're really just
doing a hard push but sooner or later
if the team is worth their salt at all
they they know the score and they back
up on you and then if you run around a
corner with a shotgun you just get
blasted before you can get close to them
so it's really
yeah don't rely on your shotgun as
primary ammo like that's the key
is to find a a primary that's useful and
complements
shotgun well is good at medium range and
then wait for
uh opportunities when somebody's running
around a corner recklessly
or thinks that they have you in a corner
because they hit you with a grenade or
something like that
and then you pull out your shotgun and
you turn the tables on them really
quickly and it's good at
uh that's kind of the main advantage of
the shotgun is when things get tight
and your uh your opponents think that
they have you you can one-shot them and
that's
how i use i run around with chaperone or
uh duality
uh and and just you know uh
to tap people at me medium and close
range whenever they uh
they think they've got me uh and i think
that's that's the
best way at least for me that's what
works with using a shotgun is to
be humble and don't use it as your
primary ammo i think
agreed i think the other thing that's
applicable to both uh
an accompaniment to any special weapon
um is always be ready with your primary
right after
you take a shot so for me that was the
biggest thing is i don't try to go for a
double body
if i get a body i already have my my
primary out
um ready and then sometimes i'll click
ahead and i'll have my primary out it
also helps if there's two enemies there
well maybe one you didn't see you've got
your primary
ready to go in case you have no sniper
ammo left so or shotgun ammo whatever it
is and then you're ready to quickly
follow up with your primary
so quick swapping between your uh
energy weapon or sorry your your special
weapon and your primary weapon is huge
like pull out that primary right away
don't be prepared to do a double body
because it's a waste of ammo
first of all usually if you've bodied
them you can clean it up with your
primary
um but also it just better prepares you
in case there's more enemies and then
you can team shoot as well
so that's a big one for me on both
shotgunning and sniping
hard to go wrong with those yeah
there you go e so this has been let's
help ubontis a new segment on the last
word that we're going to do every week i
assume
depends on the guest but definitely
having a crucible focused lady on here
is a good time to do that
so thank you for that i'm not even that
good
you'd beat me i'm pretty sure i'm
average
and humble apparently so yeah
travis is addicted to segments
transitions and runs of show
yeah like format okay i like
come on we gotta foreign through this
thing in order he's like do you ever run
a show and i'm like
we got a general idea it's like we just
typically let it flow so
yeah but as for kind of
the actual activities going on in this
game that we're playing currently
depending on if you're playing it that
actively or not
i don't think anybody could miss the big
twitter
post i think it was wednesday in green
the wonderful tease for what is coming
in the future so i wanted to get you
guys
takes uh sarah you get to go first since
you are the special guest
so okay what is what are your thoughts
about any in it because you know first
time being we talk about this stuff all
the time but it's like first time being
on the show
thoughts about anything that could be
coming on the 24th or in the future
table's yours so go nuts i have no idea
i
come being someone who never i never
played d1 i
i honestly have no clue what's going on
with this story most of the time
i'll be honest with you i'm a
transgressive
if i didn't have a conqueror title and i
didn't have a day one vlog emblem
i would be like i i don't ppe ever but i
i do occasionally but i still don't know
what's happening in a story so
i really have no idea i know that they
haven't really done
these kinds of teasers recently or like
at all so
like lately um so but i have no idea
what's to come
i also am at the point in this game
where i just keep a very open mind and i
try to manage my expectations
just so that i'm not disappointed
because i think um the community as a
whole can get super worked up and
excited
and have high expectations for things
and they're kind of let down when it's
just like
not what they expected or not what
they'd hoped for and if i manage my
expectations and i just
you know i'm like i'm curious but i
it could be really nothing then usually
i'm surprised and i'm pleased by the
outcome so
that's where i'm at with it i don't have
any clue what it means
i'm behind on my story missions actually
that haven't done the most recent uh
i think this season's been i missed but
it's been good
i still don't really know what's going
on but
i've only missed two so far anyway
i i have a lot of thoughts so i'm well
before you go
let me ask sarah one more thing uh when
it comes to which queen
as expansions obviously are substantial
to the game
shadow keeps beyond light and then
potentially which queen or whatever the
hell they're gonna call it because that
name i don't know if it's gonna stay
um what do you want from it
being a pvp main especially pvp maps i
was gonna say i mean this is a t-ball
question but it was like for you i mean
as a pvp player who like you know what's
going to help keep you invested what's
going to help make the
you know what's going to help you stay
in the game more as opposed to when you
said maybe
maps that's really it that's all i
really care about right now
anti-cheating maps shortly
i'm i'm again i'm managing my
expectations i don't i'm not asking for
a lot and at this point being someone
who again didn't play d1
i'd be willing and accepting of them
bringing back old maps
just because i've never experienced them
that being said to keep the community
old game modes would be good i have
heard great things about a couple old
game modes that i would love to try
that i never got to play yeah so um
so that would be super cool i really
really need a better anti-cheat that
being said i've heard things have been
pretty good recently
i haven't done trials yet this weekend
but um
i voted an anomaly by the way just so
everyone knows oh
boy phenomenal it's really good for my
titan builds
that's that is but anyways that's if
if all we got out of which queen were
those two things i think the community
would be much happier
that being said i still don't have high
expectations and i'm expecting nothing
just for crucible specifically i am
excited to see what they bring out pve
wise
and for the story even though i don't
know what's going on it's still
fun especially to watch everybody else
experience it alongside me
um but yeah i'm managing my expectations
i don't
have yeah we'll see fingers crossed
rift was the greatest thing that ever
happened to destiny
uh yeah it was an amazing bit of a high
bar there sir
how dare you how dare you sir rift was
four before
no it was a three three i think it was
six seasons yeah
what's the the kill confirmed
no it was the one where you had to like
salvage that's the one i'm thinking of
oh maybe wow i forgot that was in the
game right
a little while that turned into salvage
sadly turned into you don't want to pick
it up first because it was hard to
defend then to get it
so it's like the game mode was broken
for a while but yeah
yeah uh rift was like a capture the flag
game mode where
okay i guess it was more like bomb
because it was it was you capture the
middle you capture the middle and have
to dunk on their side it was more like
an assault game mode because there's
a rift in the middle teams fight for it
and then when you get it you have to
fight to the opposite team side and dunk
it into their
side so it's like a an assault uh game
you could
back flip for style points yes
and you can backflip to get more points
so it was cool because it made like
mobility
matter more uh people can help even if
they weren't good at killing you could
still help carry and do sneaky maneuvers
and
stuff like that this was really cool um
and i don't know why they took it out
but
that game mode came with the taken king
which
was sort of there's a lot of parallels
between the taken king and sabathon
because this is sort of like the sequel
to the taking king in a lot of ways
because we're fighting
uh oryx's sister so um this will be
uh this would be a great time to
reintroduce it is my point but yeah i'm
with you
we badly need crucible maps i think we
need at least one new game mode
anti-cheat obviously people on pc would
like that i don't care i play on xbox i
abandoned pc because of cheaters a long
time ago
uh but i do hope they fix it for your
guys's sake and that being said like
with crossfit coming out like it would
be nice for you to feel like you can
play with your homies right
that's true but yeah so yeah you can
turn it off but how nice would it be
if that wasn't at like you know for you
to play with your pc buds without
feeling like
cheating is going to be a component like
my entire clan is on pc
uh yeah none of them play on xbox so i
uh
i think it would just benefit everybody
yeah i agree yeah oh no
absolutely i do i do think they'll at
least address anti-cheat just based on
their hiring they've hired a whole bunch
of people to tackle anti-cheat recently
and i would be
really surprised if they'd made zero
progress toward toward their
like things are already feeling a little
better so
so yeah i don't know maybe they've done
some stuff behind the scenes without
announcing it which would be the
smartest
like dmg called that guy out that was
beautiful we talked about that last week
i already had him blocked honestly but i
so i didn't really know what was going
on and then like it came up in my clan
chat and i was like oh
okay well it feels like i it was like
working out well
you know we usually go through our
security checks and then he got back him
later after checking
fired like just triple checking yeah
shut it down multiple account four
accounts have been banned that are all
attached to you
it's over it was so perfect it was just
a professional mic drop and it was
beautiful to watch
it was i that's a great way of putting
it a professional mic drop
yes that's exactly what it was yeah so
what about you
travis what are you looking forward to
in the world of which queen are we going
to open this can of worms
oh yeah dude let's open it well first i
have i have some notes
as usual i i find a way to complain
about everything yeah the good news
i have opinions this man has pages of
notes
i diary about this every night dear
diary today bungie hurt me
in the following ways um no uh
they changed sabbath and sigil again i
don't know if i haven't seen anything on
the internet of people now
we've had a great week in the fast and
furious uh
uh community family the memes yeah
yeah the memes have been very good
they've been great yeah so that so they
changed sabathune's logo again that's my
first note my second note is
survive the truth is while provocative
means nothing really i mean like it's
just a really weird way to put it is all
i have to say i get what they're going
for i think they probably wanted to
somebody gave a cl a sub to mcclunkey
there's somebody named clunky in chat i
don't know
i'm sorry i just saw that in the notes
because he's travis and then all of a
sudden there's mcclunkie
there's a mcclunkie in chat there's a
clunky in here shout out to mcclunky
um yeah so that's my second note but
uh i am very excited i think i think
this is going to be
like seasons of arrival season of
arrivals
for the witch queen it's gonna be like
my my tweet when i first saw this was
it's a season for dominoes to fall i
think it's gonna be just
stuff happening and set up for the witch
queen i think we'll probably see
osiris turn officially and either
that'll be the
the kind of starting off point or it'll
be something that we as the player know
that our characters haven't figured out
yet maybe we'll see kind of
cut scenes with him doing some shady
stuff but i think that will definitely
be revealed at some point during the
season
at one point or another um and i think
other stuff that's sort of
in the planning stages will start to
happen i think we'll start to see like
dominoes fall and changes and the witch
queen will feel a lot more real over the
next season that's my theory
and they have a ton of time with the
season because of the delay i think it's
like a
six months easily probably yeah it could
be as long as they want it and it's like
that's the curiosity of things i'm
wondering if they'll show the date
yeah so docker i have no idea if they'll
show the
the date i i feel like they probably
have to at least give us a window or
something
some expectation but either way the next
season i think that we're gonna see
announced has got to be
um kind of feel more like a trickle
because it can't just be dead forever so
i think it's
they're really gonna they're really
gonna stretch it out i have no idea how
they'll do it it'll probably be a drag
on the community like it always is when
you stretch stuff out
for sure yeah but the breadcrumbs i
think
uh they need to they need to they have a
lot of work to do i think to make
sabbath
feel real before the witch queen because
if sabathan just shows up in the witch
queen and then we kill her a couple
hours later
i think i think players are frankly
pretty oh they're better tired of that
and i think it would be great if they
spent the eight months actually building
her up as a villain and making her
someone that we haven't been able to
beat yet
and then use the witch queen season as
us finally beating her you know what i
mean
something like that i mean i'm one of
those guys who's just said for years
that like
we need to not actually kill the villain
and it would be great if they could get
away and come back
that would be that way yeah we have a
relationship with them for longer than
uh that's true that's a good point um
i've always thought that they should do
that but
if they're not willing to do that which
i don't think they will be given the
fact that lightfall is next and that's
probably going to be a completely
different thing
i think they should at least use those
eight months to build a relationship
with zavithun and make her
a force to be reckoned with i want us to
lose for eight months
i want it to be eight months of just
guardians getting beat before the witch
queen comes out and we actually get to
push back
i would love that um because then that
would that would build
the hype and build her up as a villain
for all that time but we'll see man
i think um i think we've got a good
a good expansion ahead of us and it's
really just all about how they
introduce us to that expansion over the
next six seven months or however the
heck long it's going to be
uh before she makes her appearance but
i'm super excited man
the story's been crazy yeah cyrus is
definitely suss
as we discussed last week osiris is us
don't take this as a spoiler because
nothing is happening it's fine i'll
probably need my chat to tell me exactly
what's happening anyways because usually
i'm like okay i'm done what happened
it's all
very subtle stuff right now actually it
is just people like me who are reading
too much into it and there's a chance
that we're wrong but
i really don't think so at this point so
it just seems like
uh you know sabathune has her has her
tentacles
wrapped around uh different events in
the in the the tower and
a lot of people are speculating that
osiris is under her uh influence
in some way so yeah yeah it should be
pretty cool though i'm very excited to
see uh where it goes and uh
i couldn't be more hyped for this stuff
i'm one of those guys where like i don't
mind putting destiny down for months at
a time while comp there's a content
drought like i'm totally fine with doing
that but
i get hyped as soon as there's an
expansion like i love new destiny
content
destiny's biggest problem is it doesn't
have enough content to
satiate the starving masses that want to
play this game every single day and uh
these are the rare unless you're pvp
unless you're people now even yeah
especially
we don't have any content oh my god
you guys last longer than some of them
though because you have that to fall
back on
pvp mains have been starving in the
desert for like five years yes
i drag out my pve content through the
whole season though because i dabble in
pvp the whole way through so i try to
switch it up
because i need breaks from pvp too
because right
damn right now like i mean it's the meta
is getting better
but like like i'm so glad 140s are
back in the game they feel relevant
again but like
i still need pbe as well um like i still
do raids and i'm i'm planning on you
know
pretty much once i'm tired of pvp then
i'll go and do like my gm's to like
guild my conqueror and like all that
kind of stuff so
nice she's a gamer yeah yeah but yeah i
just new content needs to happen
and uh anytime we get to learn about
what they're cooking up
that's exciting stuff yeah i was like
for me it's
kind of with you guys where i know we're
looking for stuff out to witch queen but
yeah it's like the timing of it's very
specific because
they have the hint of which queen even
though the logo see keeps changing so we
have to think it's still related to
which queen by the color it's green so
that at least seems to be one consistent
piece
uh it does seem timing wise whatever
they're to tell us about what's coming
in the future they have to tell us the
day the season launches because they're
probably going to
start explaining things that are coming
when the season starts
because when season 15 that story kicks
off it's directly going to tie into
which queen so
i feel like they're gonna tell us both
but they can't tell us too much at the
same time
so it's this weird line where they're
gonna hey this is a tease of all the
stuff we're coming and working on
and they could be like hey there's
systems we're working on story has these
things and then here
and then go log into the game i'll be
very curious like server's always for me
it's like for you
i guess west coast it's going to be what
10 a.m pacific for you guys
and then so it's probably gonna be eight
o'clock in the morning or nine o'clock
in the morning that hour before they'll
do that
you know stream or vidoc or whatever
they post like right before when the
servers are down or something when they
take that down and then post it all up
and then you go and go live and then if
you're trying to create content you're
like i can't do both crap
moment that's i um that moment it's like
here's the vidocq to cover about a whole
bunch of new stuff by the way new season
go
crap i need two of me yeah um yeah
that's
is that the day the new season's coming
the 24th yeah it's exact same day and
they said they usually like to do them
in the morning on the west coast i'm
like
you're going to do it right before the
new sea the servers are going to do it
go down probably at like
9. vidoc or the stream's going to go
live you'll have about an hour
patches all that stuff and then go play
your new season i think that's how
they've done that before and i think
that's how they're going to do it again
so i feel like the timing requires
season 15
to as you said set up the dominoes to
fall
it's going to start doing things because
it must be strategic
it must be strategic like they must be
talking about some stuff that directly
ties into the new season
yeah because then everybody's excited to
log on and like
gives you a little bit of info that i
feel like they wouldn't do that all in
the same day that's a lot for them too
if you think about it like a new season
going live servers are already stressed
like
their whole team is going to be ready to
deal with like you know
bugs whatever and then they're also
doing the vidoc
the same day like it's a lot so i feel
like that's got to be
very strategic this is all serious two
weeks before
which queen was supposed to launch
originally right
yeah so it's almost like this is when
they would do their
reveal of like here's what's going to
happen with the witch queen
and yeah now the the actual launch date
is further down so
they've got this extra season of padding
they can do whatever with whatever they
want and i hope that they use it as an
opportunity to
build the hype and the story and the
narrative leading into the witch queen
instead of making it like kind of like
what a rivals was which was there wasn't
really a lot happening in that season
it was sort of all just going hey
there's this new expansion we have
coming
this fall and this is sort of just
getting you hyped for that but there's
not really a whole lot going on
because it rivals the season that we had
for like months and months and months
and months a month yeah and it was the
one where the ships were
showing up
and yeah that season and then it dragged
on forever
it dragged out it was a drought it was
oh
yeah they had those giant pyramids show
up in the sky boxes but then they didn't
really do anything all that season
and then it was just like oh here's a
picture of the director
bye i'm like and then the director
disappeared yeah
oh and have we talked about that that
thing that happened in the rest of the
solar system in like
nine months nope i haven't touched that
one yet
yeah those type of dangling threads are
what's killing me sometimes in the story
but
as you guys have also said chosen was
good storytelling some of the best that
we've had
and then this season is just like
crushing it between like the interaction
with the fallen the setup of the fallen
camp
then we've actually had myth rex talking
with us going through
oh cesarous has been going on we've had
the expunge the little subtle things in
expunge where it's i gotta keep
cognito here in spirit at least so yeah
um
all the little stuff that they've been
setting up as you said and then if you
go into this season
or you think about this season with the
suspicion that osiris
potentially has been you know kind of
taken over by sabathune or he's
kind of being used by her it
really gives this season a whole lot to
think about it's like he some of the
things he says are just way too crazy to
be
even anything but just suspect so that's
why
i will be curious what happens with
epilogue to see where we go into the
season because that's
something now do i have high
expectations after like the closing
ceremony nope
the closing ceremony of guardian games
was nothing
and so at least epilogue is two weeks
long and not a weekend
and i'm gonna be gone for when it
happens so supposedly there's some story
thing that's gonna happen
but outside of that i don't know but as
for like witch queen itself
man i'm i'm excited and i keep saying
it's like take the time they want to get
it right
because you know pvp maps modes
if they need an extra couple months
launch it march launch it in april it's
like i know there's gonna be a big gap
but i think there's a lot of people
who've been waiting on so much at this
point if witch queen doesn't land well
you could wait an extra couple months
but if it comes out early in its botched
that's gonna be a problem
i think i know it's always like is this
the season that like makes or breaks
destiny but there's a lot of weight
that i keep listening in different
podcasts and places i think there's a
lot of weight on this season more like
not more than normal but i think this
season does have a lot of weight on it
or not this season right which queen and
i think i think it has to do with the
way they branded it as the beginning of
this final
trilogy of the expansions that's going
to kind of end the darkness and light
uh because they because they kind of set
beyond light up as that first
uh chapter in the trilogy and then they
retconned it and we're like no we're
gonna do an extra year
and i get why they did it is because uh
you know i mean i reviewed
uh beyond light for ign and i gave it a
seven which i don't think is what you
want
for this this trilogy that's gonna end
your series you want
uh a nine like the taking king i think
the taking king has like a nine or
something close to it on metacritic like
that's sort of the
the and i think that's what they're
hoping this will be i think this is like
hey destiny 2 is back
and it's off on the right foot and it's
got all the stuff you want
and i think a refocusing on pvp and
showing that they're still dedicated to
doing that
and really nailing the story with the
pve content and doing some of the stuff
that they've
i feel like they've been setting up for
this whole time uh could be great and
and then uh
all they have to do after that is show
us what they have planned for the
expanded universe that they've been
telling us about for a couple years now
uh with other stuff going on and
apparently other games they're working
on that possibly are in the destiny
universe and all that stuff so
there's a lot to uh a lot to live up to
but i think you're right
i think i think there's tremendous
pressure for this to
be what they've been waiting for or you
know maybe they add another year to
destiny
next year is the beginning of the final
trilogy i feel like it's this like
we're constantly like fighting with
ourselves like yes take the time you
need to make this a really good season
but also like
that drought is really hard for us to
get to and also that drought puts more
pressure on them
and also increases our expectations so
the longer they take
the more we're like okay they're taking
extra time to make this really great
so it's like is it is the significant is
there going to be a massive difference
between them releasing it
earlier or four months later like
it's just like i i still manage my
expectations like i just don't yes
that's the biggest thing
no if that's if that's actually gonna
happen so
um but i do agree and i think that
there's a lot of content creators big
content creators that are
kind of looking at which queen is like
this is gonna
like this is the start of that trilogy
like this is gonna
basically decide whether this is a game
that i stick with or if i start really
diversifying my content and
going in a different direction because
yeah like it's
there's a lot of people that i think are
have been for a year or so that are like
yeah this game like it's just they keep
saying it's gonna get better
like more pvp content and it just
doesn't so
i don't know yeah i was like it's
different
no it's like pvp i do less than i do
more pve stuff but it sounds like i mean
you guys are balanced you still raid you
still do all those things so it's like
you have the big stuff you hit the tough
stuff it's just if you're gonna leave
somewhere you're like i'll just probably
go play crucible with me i'm like i'll
probably go
do you think also pvp mains are better
at pve
learning pve than pve mains are at
learning pvp
i believe i actually believe that our
shot is already on point like we're
killing those drakes like no other like
i'm hitting all head shots okay
i can go into a raid with thorne and i'm
like no problem
yeah you should see my pve kd ibantus
yeah
off the book you wouldn't believe it
yeah
i've already perfected like making
builds my mods are like
top-notch good to go
yeah that's actually probably a fair
point the thing is the thing is i think
we've talked about this before i would
be curious to hear
uh your opinion small hat i've been
telling
ian cogg that pvp mains
would just play a different game that
has better better pvp
if it weren't for the fact that
destiny's part of this ecosystem that
you get to
hang out with your friends in and the
fact that it has pve
is part of the reason pvp mains put up
with the fact that pvp
has a ton of shortcomings like if you
wanted a better multiplayer experience
there's a lot of games you could play
but they don't
have as diverse an ecosystem as destiny
and that's what keeps us around so
we're interested to hear if if that's uh
i agree with that yeah i um
and i mean for me too i think destiny is
my comfort zone at this point because i
haven't tried out a ton of other fps
games so destiny 2 is just my comfort
zone
i like it here i'm good at it i'm
you know not quite ready to go to
another game to feel like a noob again
um i will i'm gonna be i'm
trying to play more halo and like
actually branch out a bit
i want to i'm working through all the
campaigns right now and then i'll get
into pvp
and then i want to get through
everything kind of before infinite comes
out
so are you on the halo insiders program
yet
sign up for that because they're going
to do that beta for halo infinite this
summer
and if you sign up for halo insiders now
you can you can play it when it's uh
a lot of pressure it's my recommendation
it's good content right there
plus good content just just you know
it's a test it's a tease just you know
dip your toe in the water see how it
feels yeah
but yeah if you're if you're trying to
figure it out yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty fun but i do agree
i think that um for me it is uh
like i i do play like all aspects of the
game um
i don't i definitely perfect for pvp
yeah i haven't played gaming like since
i watched it this season
i i i get i get to light level cap
without
my gambit okay does it even help you
anymore does it give it yeah
it gives you one it gives you one plus
one pinnacle but that's it
yeah yeah it's not worth it well
no no no per week it's a weekly like
plus one weekly pinnacle yeah the reason
i stopped touching it is because last
season when they did the seasonal
challenges
you'd look through and be like oh
there's a gambit thing and there was the
one for the ranks and i was like
all right fine i'll do one crazy stupid
stream and i'll work through the range
because it was triple in for me and you
know you get rolling fine
then like weeks later it was like get 40
in like get 40 kills in gambit and i'm
like
and it's not retroactive i stopped
every gambit playing at that point i'm
like if i'm gonna play gambit i'm gonna
wait till the end of the season
when everything's already available
because if i'm gonna touch any of those
seasonal challenges
they better all be open or if they're
not retroactive it's crap so
fan theory for uh witch queen uh the
drifter
shows up and he's got a really long
beard and he's super overweight
and he's like does he go did he go
adventure store
and he comes out and he's just like all
right all right all right
you guys ready to and then and then 50
years old what happened
yeah exactly well we need to do that so
show that he has bloated
and then we can have a redemption arc
for him that kind of rebrands that
working with him on his nutrition
putting him on the treadmill working out
with him got some weights in there
it's kind of a rocky montage of like
trying to get him back into shape and
also trying to fix gambit as a game mode
and then
he kind of gets rebranded maybe he can
have that uh the man bun now
you know he goes yeah he goes uh oh my
god you've waited
this is one of your diary writings i
think this is
for sure would yeah and then it would it
would also make me feel like okay well
gambit's a different mode now even if
they changed nothing about it
seeing his arc i'd be like well it must
be different now so
it feels different he's got that old
scraggly voice
i'm in here doing sit-ups in the tower
please go kill the
the taking those moats yeah
oh god that one didn't i cannot say when
i started this podcast we were gonna be
talking about
fat drifter but it happened
we're here we're here now we're here
we're doing this thing um
words those are fun so
well what else happened this week
solstice
okay what else happened i'm just kidding
yeah
oh i i dropped into the eas i went and
fed the cat and i got
um i got a shotgun no and
yeah yeah i got a decent roll you know
but nice that's all i did and then i
left i didn't bring that cat yet
there yeah i actually did i do this and
i
haven't done any i might just buy
everything
i think you have to do some to be able
to buy the ornaments and then once you
can do that you can stop
it looked like i could just buy it i
don't know you just have to get purple
you have to get the armor to purple
oh that's oh the blue set takes yeah no
time at all that was quick
yeah yeah yeah so i'm busy i'm probably
just gonna do one
get the ornaments yeah i did i did my
warlock last year and i did my hunter
the year before so it's kind of
there you go it's got a little variety
sets yeah it's all perfect
yeah yeah uh yeah i i i've not been
enjoying it so far but i i also
barely dip my toes i'm busy with other
projects for igen right now but i want
to sorry you gotta at least get the
purple armor and then
you know is it is it on for a month yeah
it's four
i've got i've got plenty of time i'm not
worried about it i just honestly the
easy activity
guys i have a terrible sense of
direction okay irl
and in game and in gaming and so i'm
literally
running around trying to like figure i'm
like okay i see them on my radar
i see the marker how how the heck do i
get up there
like i i'm like trying to i'm like i get
turned around people like sorry you just
went the same way you came and i'm like
i
and then yeah next thing you know my
teammates have killed all the bosses
and i've done nothing so so it's very
frustrating
directionally challenged person this is
your first time doing solstice then
yeah the third time actually oh what i
still don't know the map
wow third time have you put into it
previously
i told you i did one character each year
okay fully oh wow
fully and still struggling because it
has been the same map
it's the same map i don't know maybe i
just block it out because it's a
terrible experience so i just
that checks out that actually i can't
know how sad my sense of direction is
like so for you going to new places
yeah crystal maps are so much smaller
though and there's not multiple levels
it's the level's the game it's the
verticality that really messes your
locality
oh my god you know i wish this game had
more verticality than jeffy reason
twilight gap is my least favorite
crucible map okay
like it's just there's too much
verticality i get twilight gap
yeah yeah i like twice it was cr it was
it was
it was actually not bad for trials a
couple weeks ago but
okay so you're going to a new
destination in real life are you just
like
glued to that gps directions or
uh yes is apple is siri talking is siri
talking you through like everything yes
you'll turn in five feet two feet no
feet go okay
yeah yeah and like
i usually like stare at the map before i
leave my house and then i
go the best plan of action is really
someone else should just drive me
but like okay great example of my
directionally
challenged uh tendencies i i can drive
somewhere so say somebody's in the
passenger seat next to me we'll be
driving somewhere
they're giving me directions to their
house for example and they're saying
turn left here turn right here
go down the street i get there and i'm
like okay how do i get home
like that's that's how like now that i'm
turned around and i have to
go back to the opposites yeah i i can't
i'd have no idea
no idea and i just listen
no idea like was it right or left here
my other left i don't know it's yeah
so anyway there it is just it's not
it's not
it's just not mine so okay directionally
challenge is that ever an issue in a
raid
oh yeah oh yeah um
oh yeah yeah yeah so okay so
you know how there was okay when um vog
came out i had got my day one
right with my pvp clan we crushed it in
13 hours
we did the whole thing with lots of
breaks and we used
numbers so we tried using the directions
and we ended up successfully completing
it with numbers
and then there was you know social media
blew up and everybody had an opinion
on what best way to make call outs for
vog
and i personally work best with numbers
just the way my brain works
and i think that's because i was like
okay i kind of picture like a clock and
like you know my
your spawn location is one so it was
always on the stairs that spawn that was
one
and that's just how and then i worked
clockwise from there
and that's just how my brain worked but
as soon as people start throwing in left
right back front close far i was like
close to you or close to me i don't know
like i just like
my brain would get so confused and it's
not saying that that doesn't work well
for some people for some people
that is just the way
that's just that works best for them we
also used some really
interesting collets at one point and
it's proof that like once you get used
to it you can do any call outs and it
was like
you know they're inappropriate but i
think i just heard some interesting ones
for your direction issues what's that
you just have to get a compass
and put clock numbers around it so make
it make more
and then you'll just know where to go oh
i'm gonna go east 3pm okay
take it three o'clock
six o'clock you can build me you need to
take a six o'clock oh like a u-turn oh
[ __ ] okay
okay done i just figured it out man
you're cured beautiful got the numbers
and directions
mixed together what i need to do for the
az2 like when i i'm gonna spawn in i
need to like okay one
two three four like you know make it a
clock
until you hit one of the teleporters get
launched up into the air and then you're
above the whole map and you're in
trouble
no yeah okay maybe that won't work i
don't know
like where am i i don't know i'm way up
in the sky hell
no i was like for me i did i grinded out
my solstice i got us a magnificent and
i'm
on my titan and i'm done like i
i did not really even want to but i was
like i just kind of wanted to knock it
out
because once you have that then you can
master work it sometime in future life
if you care to even though the stats
suck so i don't know why i really would
because that's not gonna help the stats
which isn't which really kind of sucks
like you get the magnificent set and i'm
like
51 stat room like why do i have this
you do the master works by that too you
do the master working thing so it'll
you or you do the requirement so it
glows but it's not better
and why would you mass work out when you
can just at that point
like just do yeah just do the whole
transmog
which by the way love transmog yay they
you do or
sorry i love it i actually okay the
process could be better but like so far
like i've transmogged quite a bit and i
still have a lot of
things left so and i do it all in all
three characters but i've transformed
like three full
little outfits for my hunter and
like a couple for each my other
characters so it's really end game
so you play hardcore destiny
i never was and then transplant came
around and i was like oh [ __ ] this is
kind of fun though
yeah my titan's kind of cute like yeah
pvp mains have always had a hard time
playing dress tony because we care more
about stats than our look
yes yeah this sort of allows us to get
the best of both worlds but
exactly as i said on this show yes
it's a terrible terrible it's not a good
system terrible ecosystem
with three every game has like transmog
and like
it's all free it's just part of a game
like it's just a button
click x to transmog and this one has
three different currencies
because you have the two paid currencies
the bundles and the singles right of
course
currencies yeah eva and tess everest
like
that i think is who sabathune actually
is in the behind the scenes
so probably overall
yeah solstice overall i mean it's
you got the quest when you i think you
got the blue set of armor you get
finished that one
and then you got your shotgun which is
the one new reward and you can open
packages for a roll i think it's a
precision frame which is fine i'm sure
they're okay but
same thing after three years and i know
i'm at the point where i'm like i don't
want you to do anything else but it's
always the weird thing when you get done
with that i'm like
that was not time well spent it wasn't
enjoyable
it was not i'm just going through i was
like okay so because i was working on
the purple set i'm like all right i got
to do
how efficiently can i do these things
and put them together well i have to do
three overrides
why because the armor says so i have to
do three nightfalls
playlist activities and you just have to
go through these certain things it's
just making me go play all the old stuff
over again
i think if i'm gonna hope for one thing
in witch queen which is probably still
too big of a hope
is that some of that type of stuff
changes the seasonal
activities get a little bit of love
because i mean we're gonna see
the donning probably not going to change
we're going to see
festival lost i still don't know how
festival is going to go because
technically mercury's gone but i'm sure
they'll bring it i don't know how
they're going to do that
never stopped yeah no it's like it's
still probably coming oh well we got
access to mercury through this like dark
portal from gambit over there so well
yeah i i it has never stopped them uh
like
there was this uh eternal darkness but
the edz still was broad daylight every
time i visit
this season okay festival lost is going
to be the same the dawning is going to
be the same
then witch queen after that the events
need some freshness
so like i can i can be patient for witch
queen but at that point
i gotta i got to see some freshness in
some of these events after
after this one and knowing probably
what's gonna come in a long season while
they work behind the scenes on brand new
big thing
those events are gonna be exactly the
way these are and it just gets me even
less excited about that downtime in
october and december is gonna be rough
like i already have a big enough to-do
list irl i don't need a big to-do list
in-game
i just don't yeah i don't like to feel
like that's what i'm doing i don't
feel like i'm like literally checking
things off a to-do list because i have
to
like if i get into the game i just kind
of want to play what i want to play
and that should be the case like i don't
know
she's my people e she's anti-teddies of
the world
oh yeah teddy one of his buddies is the
100 um triumph score
everything he's the he's the opposite of
us he does
checklist and when he's done with the
checklist he logs off
and for some people that's like
satisfying for them like they just
it brings them a certain amount of
satisfaction in a game uh his might be a
compulsion versus a satisfaction
he's a prisoner he really is a prisoner
of his own
hobby so yeah
yeah no not a fan i just that's
that's why i just headed and play pvp
same yeah ditto people like why are you
grinding trials this weekend and i'm
like because i feel like it
you feel like just experiencing pain all
weekend yeah i mean yeah
it's more fun basically a lot of other
things in this game like i just like
competitive
game modes i like to win so
yeah give me good i get a lot of hate
for playing trials all the time but
hey you have fun doing it nobody can
tell you otherwise so nothing wrong with
that
yeah well before we get into the sandbox
i did want to get the two
crucible players thoughts on the sandbox
i wanted to ask you guys your thoughts
about master
vault of glass to see if you guys have
any opinions if you even know what i'm
talking about first off if you've been
watching but
why thoughts about you know just kind of
the feel in the community the rewards
and you know the time and effort and
limitations just thoughts on the whole
way they handled
master vaulted glass both of you guys
are shaking heads in different ways
so who wants to shake their head first i
haven't run it yet
but i've i've talked a lot about like
we've talked a lot about like
what's happening with it i personally
don't have a desire to do it which says
a lot i do
like vaulted glass um
i love grinding for new weapons like i
like getting new weapons and
personally don't i have no desire to do
it it's just more champions
which is also just kind of a poor
mechanic in this game imo but um
more champions um i don't mind the light
level
like i think it's good to make it
challenging that's fine
but as far as the rewards go uh it just
doesn't seem like it's worth it
so yeah yeah i i'm with her
i i honestly think this is the worst
like heroic
raid they've ever done because back in
the day heroic raids actually
used to be more than just like beefier
enemies i mean there were some where
they just added yellow bars and that
wasn't good like i think crota's end
kind of had that with the heroic mode
for that raid but they at least had
different challenges or there was sort
of like a
a different take on a certain encounter
but now they've sort of
uh spoiled that already by having
challenges with the based raid and so
now by the time we do
heroic it's sort of just like make them
chunkier make the
make the more champions uh make the
grind to actually play the mode more
than it should be which that honestly to
me that's the worst part because i
i'm a pvp main so i level up just
tragically slow because i don't i don't
do a lot of the stuff that gets you to
level up fast
and uh and that that means that i'm not
even high enough power to attempt the
master vaulted glass but just
super frustrating for casual players
because i think that that
something like a master bog need like it
does need to be accessible to casual
players like not everybody
like myself has time to grind out all
day every day like i just
yeah yeah i don't think so doesn't it
cost
it costs spoils to get the adept weapon
at the end
is that correct one by doing the
challenge but if you want to buy any
more it costs like
more spoilers which i don't even know
how much more it costs actually don't
know the cost 25 or 35
or something i don't even remember for
the high level does anybody in chat know
how much the time lost weapons cost for
spoils if you do know let me know
but i do think it's more yeah i don't
think anybody's hurting for spoils
really like
i think i'm maxed out all the time on
that currency 25
20 25 that's not that bad okay so yeah
yeah i mean
that's not really i think the rewarding
part of it well obviously
it's not rewarding enough because we're
we're all like the
tri-hardiest of the trihards and i don't
know if any of us have played it but
at least uh a small hat and i have
haven't played it yet and we
we are their target audience with how
hardcore we are at this game so that's
not a good sign but for me it's like
the barrier of entry is their first
problem like i don't i'm not going to
grind
just so i can do master vaulted glass i
felt like yeah like i'm not doing
strikes man i'm not going to go just
like that it's still there i felt the
same way about grandmaster nightfall
like
sounds fun but i'm not gonna spend all
my time doing that
um so so that's a problem and then the
the other problem is just that like you
you just got done doing vault of glass
and now i'm just artificially gonna get
my butt kicked by
the same enemies just because they
decided to make a hobgoblin that much
stronger than me now and
and that never feels good and i i had
that same problem with grandmaster
nightfall it's like
here's a strike you've done 50 times 100
times
now do it and feel bad at it even though
it's your 103rd time you know what i
mean and that's like
well how is that a nobody likes that
like there has to be some sort of way to
mix it up a remix of something there's
there's some aspects like with gm's that
i don't mind like i do like that you
know
you kind of develop a strat and then you
can
you know you it's satisfying when you
finish it finally because you've got the
strategy down and same thing
you know i do think of it kind of like
with trials like once you get familiar
with the map you kind of figure out how
people are playing
you get you get that strat down you can
your wins are going to come right like
so it's figuring out you know how to how
to play it
to successfully complete it whereas i
don't know with vlog
i think it's we're still dealing with
the same mechanics a lot of us have done
yeah this raid every week multiple times
i still don't affect so i'm still doing
it three days a week
and uh so for me at this point the raid
feels grindy
because i've done it so many times this
season and then somebody in my chat
yesterday was like well
if they added new mechanics people would
be kind of butthurt about that i'm like
really would they like i would prefer
to learn a new mechanic to challenge
myself
then just have to shoot a few more shots
yeah at an enemy and have to bump up my
resilience because
i'm dying faster because i'm lower light
like that's just
fun do anything yeah it was just an
example but i know but
that's a whole different argument i've
had before it's like i wish
i wish stats mattered more but that's a
whole podcast in itself sorry
yeah no that's fair that's fair um but
yeah i do i personally would like new
mechanics i think that
you know the the challenges like um like
when we did
um day one we completed the raid i'd
never done bolt of glass because i
didn't play d1
i was brand new to it um we completed
the first part of the raid and then we
had to go back and do
uh con like the challenge mode and
that was fun because it is adding in new
mechanics right it's actually changing
how you you take on the encounter
whereas when you just make the enemies
harder and you add in a few more
champions you're just getting overrun
with enemies it's just not fun
it's just it's just basically you having
to play more passive
you're having to you know just put on
you know
you have to have more wells you need
more bubbles you just need
like it's just it's boring you can't you
can't change up your littles the same
way like
there's already champions you're already
being dictated what weapons you have to
use exactly
because of the champions you can't even
play around with new loadouts so it's
like
that's just it just it just feels grindy
i don't know i'm not i'm not looking
forward to doing it
people are being like oh when are you
gonna do that i'm like i just i don't
feel like it like it just and even this
week like because the weapons are on
rotation
yeah like the weapon this week sucks
like i was like no like i'll maybe do it
once like fatebringer is the adept
weapon but like
in nine weeks in nine weeks yeah like
i've heard some people it's not even for
that one i've heard it's not even a
guarantee to get the weapon
i've heard some people just get armor
and not a weapon
yeah i think i don't know if it's like i
haven't ever probably similar
it's probably the similar to gm's
because gm's like you don't always get a
weapon
like obviously at higher level of
difficulty like it's it's uh you get
higher chances but you still have to
grind it like
i've i've platinumed grandmaster
nightfalls like maybe seven times and
i've never gotten an attempt to wife
yeah most of those were on double loot
weekends too
so like
or like you know when uh
wow it's funny because i didn't actually
do dsc until
it was like two months in
i did it for the first time and my
entire clan
most of them had run like 20 plus times
at this point more than that and
i did a first try and i got it a day one
on
challenge mode and then i did it every
single week and i didn't get it until
this season yeah sorry
i have terry i have a couple climates
that were in your uh
i got so i have a special relationship
with vex that is the one gun
i got it the very first time i cleared
vault of glass on the first day it
released in d1
and i got it again in d2 it's like it
knew that
it knew you were doing it to me okay i
do have a theory though i think that the
people
that didn't get eyes like until way
later
like after a ton of grinding most people
that
didn't get it for a long time got vex
like first try or like within their
first 10
runs like your multiplier is so high it
spilled over into vex and just gave it
to you
yeah yeah yeah that's that's my theory
and now i'm getting screwed over because
i've done it
i'm zero for 18. i didn't do last week's
raids so and i haven't done this week's
yet but
i haven't done yeah yeah well uh if it
makes you feel any better
beck sucks especially for people yeah
it's like it's not great right now it's
not even worth the grind i do
like to have all my weapons yeah i just
like to have them because who knows
maybe they'll give it a buff like
supposedly and i want to have it sounds
like they're going to try to 15. yeah
they're going to allow it to take fusion
rifle mods which i think is uh
yeah actually is the future all right
all right yeah i was like no literally
hearing you talk about master vault of
class seeing what i kind of listen to
different people's thoughts in the
community
and then just mine it's like as you said
the time limitation one so you have
you have to do master first so if you
want to like hey i want to run on
tuesday and
play some streams or like any content
like any
sherpa or anything like that they can't
do any helps until they check that box
so that has to be like first thing they
do on tuesday so then they might have to
limit what they do
then the fact that this week it's only
the gateway gatekeeper one i think is
the challenge
so there's literally no point in doing a
theon on master
because you're just going to get a
normal drop from it you're there and you
can get used to it but you may as well
go do it on normal because the drop is
going to be the same yep
which is really weird so bizarre to me
they're
putting like just put it at the boss
like if you want
to actually make it challenging and
super rewarding because yeah like i
it does that does not make sense to me
so like i mean the one challenge is
gonna be active a week
you can only get one time lost weapon a
week and like
say you go out of town or you have a
vacation when fate bringer's in here
it's gonna be five
six weeks later when you actually get
another chance at a time i'm like
really so like the time gating is the
weird part for me and then as you said
the fact like
i feel the same way about grandmasters
and mastered like
you look at them grandmaster's the same
but you like hey go to the nightfalls
and just click on master and just look
at the modifiers down there and like
does that look fun to anyone i'll go do
and i'll even do like my lost sector
guides for other people
and i try and do them for like new
players like i typically do no exotics
and i'll won't even use my super i'm
like you guys can take this base load
out and get it done
use any tools you have to get it better
when i do a master with attrition it's
awful
like there are certain modifiers that
just are not fun and then you think
about like a grand master and you're
like
hey i sneezed the wrong direction i got
shot in the side of the head
those moments are just that's why for me
like master doesn't sound fun especially
if you make it
the time-gated limitation for the loot
anyway on top of the way it feels
like that's when it's not you're like oh
here's a champion i killed
okay now you just have to unload another
half a clip into it just to try and kill
the same dude
there's a sniper over there he takes two
shots instead of one and it just
um i know the artificial difficulty term
gets thrown around a lot
but i also know it doesn't feel good
when that's the only difference we're
getting
so i'm with you guys like the mechanics
i kind of like what you said because i
don't hear it often champions i think
are they crutch on them way way too hard
they put them everywhere and basically
pve and it's their only thing
overload champions are kind of
unreliable at a high level anyway like
you
super unfortunately
yeah yeah and they're teleporting is
like really wonky too
and sometimes like i i don't know it's
it's awful
yeah yeah i think i think overload is
glitched like straight up a deep
hug and then i've sat in one of the
fallen lost sectors on master and
there's a captain i
think it's i can't remember the name of
it uh it's on the cosmodrome in the
south
um and that cat first master captain
he's like
i'm like dude are you in a pinball
machine right now like that's what he
looks like i'm like how is this
how is this a mechanic i'm like i'm
gonna aim he just teleported four times
while i brought up my scope like what is
this exodus garden too
thank you stasis on them yeah that's
even worse if you mistake i was gonna
say i was gonna say like stasis in
normal
in normal situations you'd be like oh
this is a really great opportunity for
stasis but
it's not yeah it's not it's it's
terrible it doesn't
it like lets them feel faster or
something yeah
the whole champions thing is kind of up
there with like immune phases for me
like it just feels like it just feels
like a crutch it feels like
oh like this is just too easy
it's like it's like i i just like give
them some new
movement abilities give them like some
different
like like i don't know just like enhance
it a little bit get it get more creative
with it like i just feel like we see so
many of the same mechanics over and over
and over again
that are just very frustrating to deal
with and it's not fun it's just not
interesting it's just yeah like you said
that artificial difficulty like yeah
well it's also when you said the other
champions to pvp if we're
not careful yeah let's just spawn some
overloads into trouble
yeah team gets that will beat the
cheaters that's what we'll beat the
cheapest
that's your kill streak call out that's
your kill streak reward right there
in destiny yeah can you imagine kill
streak
yeah and if the barrier is on the
control point you can't capture the
point do you have any idea how much that
would actually change the pvp meta
though because you'd have to run double
primary
because you have to count for the
champions half your team would have to
run like
you know barrier and overload the other
ones have to do like barrier and
unstoppable
like you'd have to wait no no grenade
launchers no shotguns no snipers
like you'd so completely eliminate
special weapons
i think we just invented gambit on this
podcast
but i think we made damn it better i
think we actually just made gambit
better with champions which sounds
really weird
oh no 20 kill streaks
dude can you imagine kill streaks in
destiny pvp i know this is completely
not where i thought where this
conversation was gonna go
but that would actually be hilarious for
like a game-changing moment
sadly that would just be salt in the
open wound because if somebody's already
on like a
10 kill streak in destiny the game is
probably about to get mercy yeah
yeah yeah and it calls down oryx it's
like oh [ __ ]
when you said master with champions it
also limits your loadouts
so now you're having to run so annoying
run two primaries and you're like what
do i get scout rifles some and it
depends on
like okay so now you've got this season
well next season you go into master vog
and your unstoppables like
it's just the whole champion limitations
if you're just like hey
uh if you could just have any slot just
put a
mod on one of those weapons whatever you
want to use fine
but it's like you have to use scouts or
auto rifles and barriers are in this
thing like the whole time
okay well i gotta have one of those in
there and we might have something else
that's two of my favorite controls how
you play way too much yeah the whole
gambit meta
yeah sorry champion that uh
fat drifter played some call of duty got
some ideas and just went crazy so
yeah but yeah just like it also just
like makes it so boring when you just
can't change up your like it would be so
fun for us to like
you know be able to go into a master
blog and try out all these new loadouts
and like it would make
great content for content creators too
like you know this is the new loadout to
use
to run this or like to to complete this
in like uh
like speed running would be made easier
like but also more fun and entertaining
because
you can you can and the best uh in my
opinion
one of the best things about this game
are the weapons and like
how diverse weapons we have and how
they've all got different perks to them
and how they always are coming out with
new perks
and exotic weapons always have these um
uh fun aspects of them as well so like
why can't we use those in a bigger
capacity in high level pve content yes
every season not just the seasons that
it appeals to
i don't know and it also makes it harder
to grind for weapons for pve as well
because like you know one season you're
like okay sniper sniper sniper sniper
because that's barrier and also
top tier in my opinion for most high
level uh pve content
and then next season you can't use a
sniper because you literally need to use
the scout rifle not a rifle so now
you're
grinding for scout rifles and like it's
just
no i mean there's a reason i'm not a pve
main guy no you get it
like i literally for i think it's solar
weapon kills and i was like what do i
and i was just looking at demo i was
like oh
i still have tikku's dividation there
and i was using the thing i was like
damn it this is still fun but i haven't
used it all season because you can't use
bows for
anything and last season bows were
i don't even remember what they were but
it was something you would use for
champions it's like oh it was kind of in
the low downs or something yeah it was
probably barrier and i was like but i
was using bose and now i'm like
i've just been using like i've got a
night watch i've been using and it's
their way to kind of push you into using
certain things
it's their way to freshen up the meta
but sadly it's forced so it doesn't feel
as fun
as if they introduced something new that
was like hey this new weapon came out
well i don't usually use scout rifles
but that one looks cool
as opposed to you have to use scout
rifles it just feels bad
and that's just one of those so yeah
master for me i'm with you guys i'm in
no rush and i'm also not high enough
which kind of takes the last point is
like did you do enough bounty seasonal
challenges and put the hours in
the worst part when we get to august
24th
you're gonna have to grind it out again
just to go do the same raid that you
grinded out this season to do
that's the issue like oh you were close
well
try again and that's kind of one thing
so yeah
so yeah um i did want to get to the
sandbox since i do have two uh
fairly solid crucible players in here to
say the least
fairly solid yeah come on i'm trying to
i'm trying to keep you
crucible players who are sandbox experts
they're rivaling the ways of mercury's
in fallout
embrace the numbers
no i don't think that's true i think
they're writing our waves but i'll take
it
gotcha no but seriously though for the
time that if you have you guys have
spent any time in pvp since the sandbox
dropped
how's it feeling what's feeling good how
are 120s
how's dead man's tale how are the big
things that got changed how's it feeling
to you guys
um so i just played yesterday for the
first time and
was it yesterday what day is it today oh
my gosh yes it was yesterday i think i
rated you yesterday yeah
yeah and um it was i played some comp
and i played some sixes as well because
i wanted to experience it in both
and uh six is just a lot of gl's right
now
but there were a lot more 140s in play i
was able to use my baby thorne again
which is really exciting
um i was just kind of switching up
loadouts constantly uh lightweight frame
shotguns feel really good right now as
well
since the shotgun changes um and then i
went into
uh comp and didn't see any dmt i didn't
come across dmt really at all
so i'm not too sure how that feels i've
never used it i don't
even have the catalyst um so
and then there were still a lot of gl's
in comp
uh and a lot of 120s still 120s are
still really powerful i think they only
got rid of
like half a meter and they took five
damage off per shot
something like that and i used a 120 at
one point and it still felt
super strong i also think the hitboxes
and some of them are pretty
large generous yeah
um but but yeah it was really nice to
see 140s out again
um i felt like a lot of the gunfights
felt a lot better
like i just came out of a lot of games
even if we lost feeling like
it was a good game um only came across
one cheater yesterday and after playing
for like
three hours i think which is pretty good
that's pretty hype
um and yeah chappie still feels great
i'm really really really
glad that i'm a chappy mane right now
because uh slugs
slugs feel great and um but yeah i would
say that like
overall i think the changes are good um
i think that i
in two weeks i might be feeling
differently once people
kind of re-figure out what the meta is
again because i think that's what
happens when
you know we get a new patch they've
changed a lot of things about some
pretty
prevalent weapons um people are trying
new things again they're trying 140s
they're putting away their dmt and their
gls they're you know experimenting with
like different shotguns and slugs and
precision frames or whatever lightweight
frames
and uh they're trying out new things
and then you know once they figure out
the meta and that's when
i think we'll really know how things are
feeling again
um because who knows maybe people will
realize that 120s are still really
strong and they're going to
put away their 140s again and that then
everybody's just going to be on 120s
so like it's hard to know but um
so far it's been i enjoyed it yesterday
i think it was pretty good
it's refreshing to hear nice yeah
over too travis you played much or
you've been too swamped
i am i'm pretty swamped with uh work but
uh
just the reviews and previews will not
stop coming this season
but um but uh yeah i did get to play a
little bit on tuesday and my
initial thought is as i thought uh i'm
not super affected by the shotgun nerf
because i'm using slug throwers
yeah so that that's been awesome i've
gotta learn those things i'm terrible
with mine
oh dude it's honestly it took me a while
it's but like once you get it takes a
little bit but once you get it you're
like
like you just have to kind of rethink
the way it's so much more satisfying too
yeah oh you use it so differently yeah i
went back to uh yeah
i used my lightweight frame yesterday
and i was like oh this is weird but like
once you
like it's just a completely different
play style like yeah yeah
yeah so so that's been good for me it
just means that i'm more competitive at
close range and i don't have to worry
about the low skill
uh people using um whatever it's called
fell winters uh people using felwinter's
uh
capping me so which is great uh so it
hasn't affected me that much
for dead man's tail i didn't really
notice the nerf too much i
only really fire hip fire when i'm when
i'm really in trouble anyway
so uh or you know because that means i'm
out of shotgun and i got way too close
with my scout so
that that's usually a pretty pretty dire
situation the only change tip fire is
that correct yeah they did a lot of
stuff to hit fire mostly the 80s is
still pretty standard
yeah they changed something to uh the
hip fire but i haven't really noticed it
a ton so i i think
dead man's tail is still in a pretty
good place um
but yeah it should still feel strong
like i think it should still it's an
exotic
i do think it needs to feel strong yeah
that being said
i do think that like like i like i said
i didn't use it so
did they change i didn't even read what
they did to it did they change the
hitbox
and the range uh i know they lowered the
accuracy lower the aim assist for hip
fire specifically
they like kind of took down the range
help as well so the farther away
and the hip fire the less accurate you
are yep those were
that's what i was hoping and the reason
you're probably not noticing anything
either is
because you're a good player like you
still aim like you still
you know you play the game but that's
just it is i think it was you could tell
that there were a lot of people that
were using dmt that
they didn't have good positioning their
movement was crap like they're you know
they're not actually
regular pvp players that were getting
flawless and and and beating out those
good players
with dmt because yeah it was sort of a
crutch for a while there too especially
during the stasis days i was just like
all right
you know it's great i'm just going to
stay far away from these damn guys
throwing uh freeze nades at me and i'm
just gonna
you know to tap on them exactly because
the aim assist is so heavy but
i'm one of those guys i feel like aim
assist hurts me more than it helps me on
controller like i i if i could turn it
off i would to be honest
yeah no but yeah it's you know
my work my biggest pet peeve in destiny
is when
you're about to kill someone and then
their teammate panic runs in front of
them and your character
gets you you get your aim assist dragged
to them it's probably worse
your aim assist so you just
automatically get like yanked to follow
them and you're like oh that would drive
me crazy
yeah it's it's horrible dude it i don't
think it does it on pc on controller but
on
on console it does it and if i could
turn it off i would the other thing
that i heard was that on console dmt
wasn't as bad
but it just was always more balanced it
always felt a little bit more balanced
and that might be why i've not noticed
it's so oppressive
on pc that like the flinch
especially like you couldn't even with
the range so essentially people would
sit back with their dmts and their
sightings and their empowering rifts
and they would just team shoot with
dmt's mgls and it was like
um you can't even try and snipe them
because the flinch was so massive from
even like you should be able to outrange
a dmt a little bit of flinch is
obviously
necessary but it was just like
they could still three tap you easy yeah
without having to aim
and there's they're behind the sightings
like you just you just can't play
against that it created such passive
gameplay it was so
boring so boring um i don't think we've
seen the last of it i do think people
are just switching it up right now i'm
curious to see what trials was like this
weekend because jav
does tend to be a pretty heavy dmt gl
map uh for i don't think it'll be as
much trials
yeah i haven't watched it yet so or like
played it yet
but we'll see i dabbled in very little
stuff but nothing nothing intense but
i will say i didn't notice nearly as
much when it came to
hand cannons it actually seemed like
there was a lot more variety and these
are guys the nice times to play crucible
as you said when everybody's dabbling
it's like what's going on
hey this scout rifle might be good you
get killed by a gun you're like what the
hell did i just get killed
i love those moments in crucible when
you killed by something you don't
recognize you're like oh
yeah totally that actually killed me he
was like maybe i could try that or see
if it's good or somebody's just having
it like
you see somebody kill you with a random
bow and you're like all right that's
fine
but yeah okay but it's so funny because
i'm that person that like somebody kills
me like a random auto rifle and you're
like
i don't even know what that is i'm like
angry because i'm like they're just
better than me at this point because
they killed me with like a weapon that's
obviously not meta
it's they're just good at the game and
i'm angry that they're better than me
that happens to me all the time i was
like you killed me that is not a
i gotta get better all right that that
makes perfect sense yeah
yeah but but no it does seem from like
what i've heard overall i mean i've
heard
flak on solstice being pretty empty and
you know year three fine
master vog people did videos dropped
their thoughts about that one sandbox
never really not seen anything now
trials may have some feedback this
weekend to see but generally like
that was the one piece coming out of
this week that was actually positive
when the other two are kind of like
maybe not great old stuff this is too
hard this is a waste of my time
sandbox pretty good and that's nice to
actually hear both of you guys seeing
decent stuff out of that yeah
i do also think that there are some
people in the community right now which
fair enough they're just very checked
out they're very
they they enter the game already like
with this preconceived like
frustration about the game and the
sandbox
and how it's playing and the cheaters
etc so i do feel like those
people sometimes have stronger voices
than i think they should just because
they come out being like
still not worth it the game's still [ __ ]
they're still cheaters blah blah blah
and they tend to be a little less
rational about it and again
honestly can't really blame them a ton
like i know people are frustrated right
now
um but i do think we just need to like
like it is about like kind of picking
like
like go in and like get your own
experience with it like
um because i did i had some friends
being like oh should i open up the game
today it's been about a month since i've
played and people like no it's still not
worth it here i am being like i don't
know i think it was pretty good like i
played this game regularly i didn't take
a break
and i feel like it was better i felt
like you know the games i was playing
there was more diversity in weapons like
i felt like i was actually getting into
primary fights like more crouchers
around corners with their shotguns but
it's fine like i can deal with that
um so yeah i do think it's
there's definitely some people still
very angry with the game and
that's fine but definitely i try to take
those opinions with a grain of salt
we just need more maps we just need more
maps man we need more maps
that's more maps they have to address
that on the 20 if they i swear if they
don't mention pvp on the 24th
you guys are actually going to lose your
mind because if they don't talk about it
like this is you know the showcase of
what's coming in the future and be like
if you don't talk about pvp there people
are honestly going to think you gave up
or
they're doing the other ip or it's just
like my
every pvp person moved over to the other
ip
and we just have some weapon creators
and that's it like
i might be losing my mind right now but
i believe the last time we actually
heard them say something about the
future of crucible
was the vidoc when they separated from
activision
do you guys remember that off yeah we're
talking about the future of the game
there was that one liner like we're
going to recommit ourselves to refocus
we're going to focus on pvp
that's all right and i honestly don't
think they have said a word
about it since 600 days since a map
or something i mean people have those
counts and it's it sounds ridiculous but
it's going to be
since we're going to get the delay to
2022 it's going to be over
you know basically two years since the
pvp method it's going to be been over
two years
as well yeah and it's been two years
yeah
and this is like when we're talking new
content because like they've
they've addressed you know um imbalances
between pvp and pve like they've you
know separated sandboxes in a few cases
like so they've addressed like a few
things in regards to
um just like playability of it and
like maintaining it but there has been
yeah i agree i think there's been zero
zero things said about new content for
pvp
like nothing it's like they need to do a
stream
or a vidoc or something just about the
future of crucible
just over your eyes like literally just
yeah just like what are you working on
like anything are you guys like still
tweaking like
major like spawn spots like what what's
happening are you still just like
really working on the basics of pvp and
like the way it is right now like is
that what's keeping your attention like
what
what is there just no team like
is it actually non-existent i think
they're working on that other game
the pvp is working on that other bungee
game
yeah maybe that's the big fear and
wonder is that everybody moves somewhere
else but if they don't keep talking
about it that's kind of one of those
things like
when it comes to a developer like bungie
they can't show all their cards a game
could be four years out and they're like
yeah we're hiring people something it's
like it's on
like a white board right now it's not
even anything we can talk about
fair but you also have to be like we are
shifting our focus somewhere else
like you kind of got to be honest
especially pvp mains to a point because
he's so important yeah like you got to
tell us tell them
something to be like we are going to
work on this and that's what i was like
that's why i keep saying like witch
queen continues to have a little bit
more weight because
you guys talk about this type of stuff
and then i'm like if you don't do like
if pvp doesn't get focused out there
people are going to be like throw the
desk over i'm like you know i'm kind of
dead there's gonna be moments where it's
like
all right i've waited long enough it's
700 days and i can't get a pvp map and
now there's no commitment
i'm out like exactly i feel like people
are waiting for
that type of stuff then they've got such
a loyal player base like destiny 2 has
such a loyal player base
people that play destiny 2 and like play
it
all the time especially their content
creators like stick with it like it's
their main game they
love it you know like such a loyal
player base take advantage of the fact
that your players are loyal and just be
transparent with them
and if you if they have to be like we
don't have a team right now
you know we are this is what we're
focusing on
at least our expectations are managed
and at that point then we can say okay
i'm less angry now because i'm just
gonna go somewhere else like
just rip the band-aid off for me now
honestly like
if if and then at this point i'm like
okay well i'm just gonna play the
current content until i'm tired of it
and then go somewhere else
and that's like because regardless
they're gonna lose players if they don't
say something
yeah and it's like you're gonna be
honest and and they'll at least kind of
come to peace with it good bad or
otherwise or you're gonna piss them off
so much that they leave
and i feel like the second one's worse
if you don't and they're not going to
want to support you in the future like
that's the thing is like you want to
maintain your player base a point where
like you're like i appreciate knowing
that and now i can make a decision just
based on the content that i have
and the content that's coming or the
lack thereof i don't know i just think
transparency especially with us
i mean i mean bungie's like a smallish
studio you know now that they've left
activation activision like
i just think that transparency is really
important and people want to support
them so badly
but they just they're giving us nothing
so
yeah it feels it does yeah i think the
pvp player base just starts to feel like
okay like if you don't care about pvp
just tell us if you don't care about me
it's like a relationship like if you
know what you don't want to be with me
it's not you it's me no it's not you
it's me
why tell us when they could show us over
two years how much they don't care about
us yeah
yeah they're just having their cake
they're just having their cake and
eating it too
these people are still playing the same
we took maps away they're still playing
the old they're still playing they're
still gunkers yeah
how long we have in stasis so we didn't
fix it for like a year
they're just laughing at us at this
point oh and the second lasting
talk of the destiny 2 community the sad
thing is you know
they know that's why it kills you
because it's like
they're so data driven they play the
game
that's one thing i'll give them they do
play a lot but it's like how can so many
people ask in one
like ascendant nomad he hey i built you
how comp's gonna work and then you've
got
uh kuje putting stuff together for like
sub classes and all these things
nothing and it's like i know you have
stuff you've got to do
and i think that's one of those points
where yeah we're
like there's a lot of stuff that it is
getting to kind of a breaking point
people it's like
seven years in the franchise i've shot
enough fallen am i ever gonna shoot
anything else like are we gonna see a
new race in the next three years
i'm kind of doubting it that i kind of
get but you gotta give us some
some freshness in the pieces of the game
the gambit note on the directory feels
like a joke
like crucible hasn't got love but gambit
just like it got worse and
kind of more useless so but you still
gotta go play it though
i think we will get a new race to shoot
at i would love to
not in the witch queen but in lightfall
that'd be exciting yeah would be nice to
see some different enemy types
and not just taken if i well yeah i
think the taken will get a rework with
sabbath
yes i think that's going to happen
that's the next move is
they can do taken versions of the new
enemies they've already introduced that
have taken
conversions taken brig taken
taken yeah taken wyvern
[Music]
what would a taken one even look like i
wouldn't do that
i'd like to take in captains with their
black floating ball of doom that like
wraps around corners i can't say on that
one enough i'm like
yeah all right now they're little like
feathers ooh they would like be like
oh i'm picturing it now
because right now it's that like four or
five pronged like void like
laser what's it gonna do it
it freezes your enemy for five volts she
freezes
you're just yeah in a master you're like
i've been frozen and i've been
killed like if you get frozen in a
high-level concept
freezes and then stomps on you yeah yeah
it teases you
follows up with the stomp move yeah
and you just see it like squatting and
going up and down they actually program
a tea bag from an enemy in the game
that's why that's why they've got such
massive thighs from all the
yeah obviously squats sidereel yeah they
have to do that
tea bagging yeah yeah that's all those
squats
hashtag hashtag skip leg day actually as
well
sounds good i think that that's the next
thing we get is a re
revised version of the taken enemies
through sabbath dune and then we get
something totally new for the last two
years of destiny
as they enter that final stretch so i
haven't i haven't been around since like
a new
like yeah
one of the big ones too yeah i came in
when like everything was already
established
everything yeah like yeah even pvp wise
like i
missed primary medical double she came
in after scoring was here because she
was using you came
for gambit
end of season of the drifter i think so
damn okay yeah so you've not seen
anything but i mean season of the season
of
uh what is it called i can't remember
but forsaken season
i can't remember what that season was
that even a season
forsaken must have been called something
because they know like
well seasoned but i think forsaken was
just forsaken and then it was seasoned
in the forge
um yeah anyway for forsaken that was
that was not too long ago it's
three three uh full expansions again
yeah
shadow keep yeah so uh three full
expansions ago so
if they don't do one this year it'll
actually be the longest they've ever
gone without giving us a new
uh yeah uh but yeah so i think that we
we have to get one they can't just keep
the sandbox in pve exactly the same for
like
seven years in a row that would be crazy
so uh please fix your overload champions
while you're at it
yeah that would be super it'd be awesome
to get rid of champions because it's
stupid
oh no i'm okay yeah if you could remove
champions
the reason i don't mind unstoppables is
because they don't get their health back
you can work them down you can kind of
control them
and especially ironically the most
stoppable of the championship yeah
like very ironic ironically the most
stoppable of the champions
and then the yeah so yeah those that's
because like if they didn't get their
health like a barrier it's like okay so
you miss the break
you don't get like a damage bonus i
could understand but when you're like oh
i didn't get that one scout rifle shot
off and i had to reload full health bar
i'm like
exactly just the thing if you don't
break a barrier champion's barrier it
should do like
three times damage on you when it when
it pulls down its barrier something like
that you know where it's like instead of
healing
yeah healing yeah it should just not
heal and it should just get like a
damage boost against you and like one
shot you with the sniper bolts or
something like that
i think that would be better than
because then it punishes you for not
doing it without making it like
okay you literally can't get through
this because you did bring a scout rifle
that had this one mod that you have to
remember to equip
and then yeah and now you have no
special left because you just like
drained your special
trying to kill you
okay well i can't yeah that's like the
annoying thing
oh man yeah you aren't even around for
the things of ammo synths
i'm sure you've heard of those but ammo
sense
like because yeah you're at the point
like no idea unlucky on heavy ammo drops
in something high difficulty and you're
like
i'm just screwed this is part of my
loadout yeah set you up
do some damage maybe polish you off with
this if i don't have the
and you have to like heavy is the only
real way to do damage and master content
sometimes you need that major thing to
depend on because everything else is
primaries
and then if you're out of heavy you're
like i'm [ __ ] out of luck
yeah that's what camera sense were a
thing where you could go to the menu
and you could use a consumable to gain
all of that type of ammo back
yep so there were heavy ammo synths
where you could just consume it
so in raids it was literally like a raid
banner
on the go everybody defend me i'm you
i'm hiding yeah i'm using a synth like
it's going to take like five seconds to
get in there and use the consumable or
whatever
but they took it out yeah they took them
out was it was it too much ammo economy
like
it yeah i mean you basically got heavy
whenever you wanted because you could
just buy hundreds of heavy ammo
yeah you get to a point where you had it
there was
so you can't just keep using them
forever but the reason they took it out
is because
it is objectively not a good game
mechanic to have it oh the way you get
ammo is you go to your menu and you use
this item like that's just not
uh like what you want in a game so they
had to fix it but i think
the way they fit the same time some of
the rng with the the random ammo drops
[ __ ] too the way they fixed it was
terrible the way they fixed it was oh
let's make even more things based on rng
and destiny and make
ammo a complete crowd it would be nice
if like certain enemies like guaranteed
drop
they did that you started destiny and
then at that point you actually know how
to sparingly use your ammo
because you're like okay this encounter
used to be guaranteed heavy ammo drops
and then they changed that to make it
rng
so they they've tried everything and
they settled on
one of the worst iterations of the
animal economy
you can't even or complete luck another
option like they could have like
had mods that like guaranteed the ammo
drops too instead it's like increases
your chances but instead
you know it would be nice if we could
like i would use up a mod slot to be
like guaranteed heavy drops from
you know uh majors or powerful enemies
yeah
exactly something of that kind i think
players probably shouldn't have to think
about it like
in any other game how often are you
thinking like oh i gotta like reserve
this ammo and hope that i get another
shot like it's just such a ridiculous
yeah just like swimming and it's about
unlimited
yeah or you at least get it enough where
like you're never like oh what if i if i
don't get ammo i'm not gonna be able to
complete this encounter it's just
impossible so i might as well wipe yeah
because there's
there should be there should be already
like enough challenging mechanics to the
encounter
that your ammo economy should be
yeah a mechanic yeah it should be
challenging enough
even if you've got unlimited heavy like
it should still be
difficult famine is a modifier that
tells you everything you need to know
right there
because that's low ammo drops and like
angie loves that modifier it's in halo
2.
i will never understand why halo it's
optional but
you or whatever mode you can activate
skulls in halo yes
and so yes there's a there's a there's a
mode called lasso difficulty which is
all the skulls are activated and one of
them is famine which is
one of the worst mods it's awful
yeah yeah in that game you just pick up
a different weapon
because that's a arena shooter so it's
different but they they love that mod
they put it in all their games they love
it
yeah not a fan well i know our guest has
some
time with her clan coming up in the
future so we can probably
wrap it up there but i did want to uh
kind of give you a chance to first off
say thank you for joining us um
been an absolute pleasure chatting with
you we had some weird tangents we went
off on but they have been an absolute
blast
um but yeah it's like as we wrap up the
show it was like to kind of give our
guests time
to let everybody who listens to this on
all the places it's gonna end up
where to find you what you typically do
what they look for in your content and
stuff like that so
this is basically the floor is yours to
tell everybody what you got going on
where to find you and what you do
if they didn't gather from the last two
hours
yeah yeah what do you do i don't know
you know stuff
you know stuff yeah where do we see
those booties shaking
oh yeah on uh twitch twitch.tv
very small hat smol uh all one word
and i will i think we should take this
moment i'll tell the story about my name
because you guys did want to hear that
really quick uh it's very simple
and actually i'm gonna bring up my ex
again because
when i first got into gaming
his name was actually large hat and so
i was like you know what i'm just going
to become small hat and so that
just became my name was just small hat
well
now i hope i never break up with my
girlfriend
and then uh twitch it was a small hat
is taken on twitch so i became very
small hat
and i was able to get very small hat on
all of my platforms so if you need to
find me on twitter
instagram snapchat um ticktalk
youtube and twitch all of them
uh it's just very small hat it's all the
same name uh there's no fancy
things in there just no underscore one
or anything
nothing uh apparently it's a very unique
name
uh so that's really where it came from
there's no
crazy story behind there being an actual
small hat
um but when people ask about it i just
say it's hat so small you can't even see
it did your boyfriend have a large hat
that
does that yeah where's the hat where'd
the hat come from for him
yeah basically his theory was you take
and when people are like i don't know
what to name myself
name something he's like okay you take
an adjective
and you give it like uh or so you take a
noun
and you give it an adjective and that's
that's your name so it could be like
it could be like uh stinky pickles or
like that opens a whole different
discussion right there angry
fresh socks fresh socks sounds better
than stinky pickles
if the stinky pickles are in the fresh
socks stinky pickle sounds way more like
a gamer tag than
i just faced off in stinky pickles and i
got tea bagged by stinky pickle
yeah i don't know french fresh socks
sounds like it would start more
conversations though
just saying stinky pickles people would
be like okay fair like
fresh pickles are kind of stinky first
socks though like
i do laundry a lot
[Laughter]
so that was that was his theory and
that's like so
yeah anyway so that's where my name came
from it's really nothing crazy
it's kind of awkward people are like oh
yeah where'd your dream come from and
i'm like oh
my god like it just happened it just
happened
unfortunately you branded yourself with
your ass
branded and it's based on just this
random thing
yeah yeah it really is and he was like
you need to change your name and i was
like
i have a little brand button you need to
change
your name yeah you can't change his name
i mean i kind
it's cool he wasn't that upset about it
it was it was chill
um yeah but yeah so very small hat on
literally all my platforms i'm very
active on twitter
that's where people can find whether i
am going live or if i'm taking the day
off or whether i'm
going to the gym or i don't know
that's that's where my life is on
twitter uh it's really sad to say
awesome um and uh
yeah i i i don't stream super
consistently right now but that's okay
uh i play mostly pvp on stream destiny 2
hopefully going to be playing more halo
um but yeah that's i don't have anything
super exciting coming up i'll be honest
i'm
chilling right now um doing a lot of
eyebrow plans
yeah and chill yeah um eventually
planning on starting on youtube but it
probably won't be gaming oriented
so um yeah yeah it's all about those
squats
all about the squats actually i'm
planning on packing up my life
and traveling north america next year so
whoa
uh i'll be taking my gaming setup with
me so it'll be like a travel vlog
probably okay um interesting yeah i
actually have uh
brother-in-law who did the live out of a
van
mini tiny rv thing for about a year so
that'll be me
yeah i'm planning on doing it for about
six months to a year depending on how it
goes and
uh it'll i get a little trailer i don't
know i'm
i live i'm i'm alone you know i'm gonna
i'm planning on getting a dog in the
next like six months i'm
adopting a dog and it's just my dog
all alone uh yeah like a loan
like a loan uh hero traveler
you can't say alone she's going to be
the lone canadian in america i mean i'm
kind of i'm alone
too that's right
here in canada all by my lonesome your
dog your dog will be great company
very very lonely
that should be your youtube channel that
should be a very long hat
oh man
well actually oh when you do your travel
blog you can take this one
you need to buy a tiny hat and where
they do people you know people take like
figurines out other than they take
pictures all over the world with them
you need to take tiny hats all over your
travels and take pictures of your tiny
hat with you and you can put
little tiny hats on a map to show all
the places you've been yes
that's adorable too look at that you
know when you think about it like little
pins actually kind of look like a hat
exactly yeah little top hats yeah
everywhere yeah little top hats
perfect you just got your branding all
figured out right here live from
that's what's what we do yes
solved your solved your next year's uh
needs we're good yeah yeah
you're hired my uh marketing managers
there we go
yes the last word podcast slash very
small marketing team
[Laughter]
very small marketing team yeah perfect
big brand small marketing here we go
yeah awesome well travis i know you've
been busy
that's the fun thing about you is like
hey what are you working on can't tell
you until later
unfortunately for most of it i can tell
you some of it so um
i'm reviewing uh legend of zelda skyward
sword for ign that game comes out
next week uh my review will probably be
late because i got the code last
night which is not
not when you want to receive a code for
a 40-hour television
game not ideal but that one should be
big
um i'm also working on the ace attorney
game which comes out at the end of this
month so i have a lot of time to work on
that thankfully
and then i'm previewing an upcoming mmo
and
an unannounced game that is going to be
i think it's i think on tuesday i'll be
able to talk about that but it's going
to be really cool a game i'm excited for
so i get to
i get to look for something on tuesday
from on tuesday yeah so you can find
all that on ign.com you can follow me on
twitter at thai guy travis i've never
heard of that website by the way can you
spell it again
twitter no no the other one the other
one yeah
that's it um yeah so you can find it
there uh you can find me on twitter at
ty guy travis and i'm also on this show
sometimes i'm on
other shows sometimes and uh yeah i'm
all over the
the web these days you also just google
me i found out if you google ty guy
travis or travis northup you get
all the stuff you need to know about
when i did your intro google me
don't google me you get a bunch of weird
amazon recommendations for
hats you should buy yeah i just don't
recommend
[Laughter]
they have to pay to get to that okay so
at least you're getting monetized
hey you got you have to support this
lady's travels
she needs to get her travels in so
support this woman
[Music]
i was gonna say you actually have now
made me afraid of
of if my girlfriend and i ever broke up
because my gamer tag on everything is
tie guy travis
so as a joke now that she games on xbox
a lot more because she's with me
she made her gamer tag thai girl travis
which makes
we had like the it was large had small
hat people thought it was the best thing
ever like he was
adorable while you're together yeah
loved it they loved it and now it the
people and then after we broke up it was
all wait where's larchat
we're just like because it was like a
and i was like there's only a small hat
now
there's always smart awkward discussion
moving on
[Laughter]
uh yeah yeah so if she becomes a famous
streamer i might have to change my tag
see the problem is thai guy travis he
only literally wears ties or suits or
anything he's gonna have to change his
entire wardrobe
yeah i'll be a different person oh my
god a mustache
what would you rebrand to like like uh
oh um
breakaway pants steve
[Laughter]
i don't know i changed my name
i'm telling you you gotta go put a ring
on it otherwise you're in trouble man
yeah it's gonna be like i'm working
oddity i'm working we're just gonna come
up with so many alternative names for
you like
hoodie boy henry
[Laughter]
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna have to just
enter he gets a new intro
every week now any week he's on this
show he's gonna have a new name
dear god thank you
thank you for this gold mine i
appreciate it so much
travis will become i lost my tie in the
divorce travis
[Laughter]
oh i'm actually crying now that was
actually a good laugh that's hilarious
well for me i'm about this everywhere
youtube twitch twitter you guys know
where to find me that's pretty basic i
always like to shout you guys out if you
made it this far you know where to find
me
but please go follow sarah very small
hat awesome creator she's gonna be
clicking some heads in pvp
find travis on typically twitter and
he's going to be shouting out his ig
interviews but go check out that tiny
site ign
they do things about games and stuff so
they're you know kind of cool
uh but yeah for episode 157 i think we
kept you a little long but i think we
definitely ended on a hilarious note so
it was worth getting here so
thank you very much uh all of you guys i
gotta go find somebody to raid because
it was like the
in the stream sending the love over to
somebody else so if you got any
recommendations sarah that you want me
to send
to anybody playing right now
that you would like to take a look i
typically try and keep in the destiny
community
yeah i do have um
one of my clan mates are online
absolutely what do you got maddox
yeah i was on um what is the podcast
destiny nerds right yeah yeah with them
a little while ago so
perfect beautiful well guys go say hey
to maddox form
us and if you guys know anybody who
wants to get entertained by some
ridiculous destiny conversation
you'll see this on my twitter on my
youtube channel and then also on
ironlord's podcast shout out to cognito
iron lords podcast lord cognito that man
is everywhere and he's too big and his
britches for us now so
i don't know how much you're going to be
seeing him but he'll be back every now
and then so
for episode number 157 thank you sarah
for joining us travis
appreciate the co-hosting sir and for
this episode it's been
the last word